housing we're going to get started in
just a few minutes thank you
foreign
good morning it is June 13th welcome to
a special committee on housing
I'm going to start the day by asking
representative Rudy to lead us in the
pledge
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty
God
um so a couple housekeeping items
Christine
um grant our researcher has put together
two memos for us one is issues regarding
housing so
um she's outlined kind of a a a surface
level or a aerial level view of
um what's going on in the state and then
another memo I have specifically asked
Miss Grant to put together which um
discusses impact fees what Municipal
what municipalities charge
and what they're used for so um that'll
kind of give us a good idea and this
kind of dovetails into our 10 AM guest
um Rainey Pelletier from New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
Rainey do you mind coming up
thank you for coming
just turn it back on
perfect nope there you go we're good oh
good jeez
okay thanks for the invite and I I think
as I understand my goal is to kind of go
through the processes for how Des
handles development uh from the
beginning to the end of the project yes
and I'll start out with saying let's say
that you're an individual that has a
bulk possible land and you want it to
create a number of lots however it could
be two lots could be 20 Lots could be 30
Lots so you would initially come into
the department for a subsurface
subdivision requirement and what that is
based on is when you create a given lot
it's all based on its ability to handle
on-site Wastewater and Wells
so in the initial phase of creating
those lots you would have to do a soil
analysis see how much Wastewater the lot
could support and that would what that
would dictate the size of the lots that
will ultimately be approved so once you
get through that process you would then
come in for once again it'll be based on
a soil test bit looking at what type of
soil you have and that'll determine how
many bedrooms you can have historically
a new subdivision we approve can handle
a four bedroom house
um where we get interesting is when you
look at older Lots or lots of record
that were done prior at the 1967. uh
generally a lot of those can't handle a
large Wastewater and on site with a well
so as a minimum we would approve a
two-bedroom house
so as that process goes through you move
on to the next phase assuming you've got
what we call a construction to install a
septic system on site
once that happens that process begins
you hire a licensed installer and a
licensed designer to design that system
we then in fact inspect the system and
if it passes the design criteria then
you would get an operational approval
and you're good to go from my
perspective what the town has for
regulations is something that we don't
regulate or dictate so if they have more
stringent regulations than any of our
regulations
statutorily they have a right to do that
so let's say now that you've created a
subdivision you've got a lot and now
you're in a protected Shoreland Zone
which is the mean high water mark the
250 feet
if in fact you're going to have an
impact on that particular site then you
would need a sure land permit
okay and that sureland permit controls
what happens in the first 20 feet the
first 50 feet or the back to the 250
feet of that particular parcel
once that permit is achieved you've got
your operational approval for a septic
now you can construct whatever you
choose to put on that site
now let's say that you've got a larger
subdivision and you've got 2 000 feet of
road or more
then you would have to come in for what
we call an alteration of terrain permit
and what that does is to make sure that
when you in fact you develop a property
that the storm water is controlled so it
doesn't go off-site going to a river
lake yada yada yada or neighbor's
property so if that's the case you'd
come in if you're impacting fifty
thousand square feet or more and it's
generally lineal on a road in the
Shoreland you would need an aot permit
if you're not in the Shoreland Zone
you're impacting 1 000 square feet which
is basically 200 linear feet of road
then you would need an alteration permit
for that
so when those things are all achieved
then you're ready to move ahead
so what local zoning requires there are
some towns matter of fact I just had a
phone call the other day and on a Town
Sutton has like a five acre minimum uh
that again they allowed any municipality
or entity is allowed to be more
stringent than the state rules and laws
but can't be any less stringent so a lot
of what happens within the state uh lot
sizes in particular may be
addressed by the town once you get
through their process then you have to
come in to our programs
um so to start it off you you're saying
that a developer will go through the
town first and then generally if it's
going to be a large subdivision
absolutely
they will go in and get it proved
locally otherwise they submit a plan to
us let's say that we permitted it they
had more stringent requirements then
they got to come back with an amended
plan so it's prudent for a consultant to
get through the town process first and
then submit to us there's also a
statutory Authority for towns to require
that they prove they approve an on-site
septic system prior to it being
submitted to us so there are several of
those I think 49 communities that
require that you get your design for a
septic system approved locally before we
can review it and and take an
application
other questions from Serene
representative
thank you uh thank you for taking the
question
um you said that
um a couple of things normally that you
approve a four bedroom
um
system for Waste Water
are there are there
um
different types of systems that that may
be uh
able to use less or more land and is
that taken into uh if so is that taken
into effect account when you're saying
like
um how many Lots you can have do you say
like if you go with this kind of system
that only takes up this amount of room
then you can do this many lots and if
you do this system you can do more Lots
or less Lots good question thank you no
I think when you look at the basic
overall design whether it be it to
subdivisional level or the individual
lot size based on the soil type on that
lot it can only treat a certain amount
of gallons per day of waste water we do
have a program where where we approve
Innovative Technologies and what that
does is it looks at this the height to
seasonal high water on that particular
soil type and may need a smaller
leaching area but it has no effect on
what that lot can handle from a
Wastewater load so whatever technology
you want to use is it's all based on
let's say you got an acre of land on
your site you need to put an on lot well
so that radius which is 75 feet has to
be subtracted out of that area then you
look at the soil type let's take a if
it's the best case scenario group one
soil then you probably would be able to
get a three or four bedroom house
depending on the technology you used
that may reduce the footprint of that
system but it won't generate any more
ability to have more bedrooms
thank you thank you for taking this
follow-up
um
what are you are you basing the uh
uh the number of gallons because
nowadays people are using much more high
efficiency
types of appliances or if someone was
trying to do like a low impact
setup then they might you know be
actually shooting for a lot less water
throughput through their property than
maybe the um the department normally
would consider for a generic house does
any of that come into
um a pla play like if they if they were
planning on
um you know maybe the department says
we're going to estimate 75 gallons per
person per you know day or whatever and
they're actually going to be
implementing you know measures that
would reduce that to you know 25 gallons
a day would that impact or would the
department be able to take into account
that those Innovative uh yeah thanks
that's a good question well when you
look at and I left representative Alec
Alexander a copy of a 1 000 rules there
are multiple ways that you calculate the
amount of loading that would be expected
to be on a site if it's a rep dwelling a
four bedroom house it's 150 gallons per
bedroom per day where we've gotten the
problems over the past years is people
will come in they claim they're going to
put in water Savers or whatever but it
doesn't accommodate larger groups on a
weekend that doesn't control how many
people are in a bedroom so it's a
conservative number the 150 gallons per
day per bedroom now if you're getting
commercial establishment it may be based
on a number of seats it could be based
on the number of servings that you have
are you serving on paper are you serving
on China that's going to be a difference
of how that Wastewater load is
calculated we have been in situations
where lots have been serviced by an
awful lot water supply a municipal let's
say is a good example and you have
metered flows for the last year to show
us how much actual use has gone into
that property or in a property very
similar then we would entertain looking
at that kind of waste flow generated but
answer your question at the the end of
the day the basic premises if you're
building a residential dwelling it's 150
gallons per day we cannot control the
type of structures that are in the
building we can't control a number of
people that are actually in a bedroom so
we continue to use the conservative
number of 150 gallons per day that has
been in place since I've been at the
department which has been since 73.
thank you
um
is do you know if that 150 gallons per
day is in statute or in rules
um and
um
can you so I live on on a property that
that um doesn't have a leech field I
only have
um uh holding tank and
um my holding tank is a thousand gallons
and based on the the uh
the Department's estimate I must be
pumping my my tank every like week but
that is
um absurd I would never do that it would
be way too expensive so obviously I
definitely control what water goes down
into that very stringently
um
the I guess can you
talk about the holding tank idea and and
how how receptive is
um the department to that
um type of setup understanding that none
of the waste unless I actually allow it
to fail
um and overflow would be going anywhere
um and so then uh you know the size of
my lot could be the size of the
Wastewater holding tank because there's
no no actual leaching actually happening
on my property yeah you talk about that
oh sure so if you've got a lot of record
or a lot that's existed for a lot of
years and obviously you don't have these
square footage of that lot to put an
on-site Wastewater we would permit a
holding tank
for any new construction if it were a
pre-67 lot we would approve a
two-bedroom maximum house on that lot
now keep in mind that holding tanks The
Tipping fees for holding tank pumpings
today is somewhere around 400 so it's
not cheap and it's not going to get
cheaper because of Wastewater plants
that get problems just getting rid of
their bio cells at the end of that
treatment process but so to answer your
question we would not permit a holding
tank for any new construction over the
years
by rule you're supposed to keep track of
your pumping receipts to see that you in
fact are pumping that tank we do approve
holding tanks when there's no other
alternative on a site
one of the problems we've had over the
years is after about a year or two and
and this isn't you I'm sure but after a
year or two it's very interesting that
the outlet of that tank has been
compromised and so what happens there's
no pumping
because the Wastewater is going out over
the edge so it's something that we can't
control
um it's depending on the situation the
people what's the cost let's say that
people weren't as smart as you
apparently have been and minimized their
waste water flows that you know if
they've got a large family let's say
let's say they get three two or three
kids they get a holding tank they don't
have any other option that's going to be
probably a four or five hundred dollar
bi-weekly treatment unless they really
look at how they can control a
Wastewater discharge so holding tanks or
Last Resort and that's the only time
that we would permit them
go ahead
you didn't really address the 150 is it
in statutory and rules that you guys set
that in rule okay thank you
and you if I might yeah I left
representative Alexander a copy of the
1000 rules it's got all of the flow
rates that would be expected to be
generated by a particular structure and
that may in fact help you representative
you cooler to see where how that changes
um representative McConkey and
okay representative Damon are you sure
I'm
sure thank you if I might
um those rules are actually on our
website as well
so
um Talons thank you
compare with national standards or
standards in other states
I I think we're probably a little more
conservative but it's tough to tell
because when you get out of New England
you go all over the country the soils
are dramatically different so the bottom
concept of any Wastewater load is based
on the soil type and how effective it is
in treating that Wastewater so it's
tough to draw a comparison by any of the
other states in the country unless you
have a good handle on what their soil
profiles are and what the expectations
of treating the Wastewater adequately
are
error
widely Divergent soil types I mean if
you're
Coastal Seacoast Sandy whatever I'm in
The Lakes Region we're all granite or
mostly Granite so
could there potentially be room for
researching a more flexible standard
well I I we were never shy away from
researching but as you well know if you
look at our budgets we have never had
the ability to have an r d program in
the section now the soil profiles
they've been in place for a long time
and I think a lot of it was based on the
soil the ability of soil scientists back
in the old days to look at a system and
determine what soil type was adequate to
treat a certain amount of waste water
that's generated I mean there's always
room to look at Innovative Technologies
and so but you're talking at a costly
event to determine that but if that
money were available it certainly
wouldn't be something we shied away from
I just want to clarify in response to
one of Representative callus questions
it sounds like there has not been any uh
adjustment or flexibility in regards to
different water output like a
development could
have all low flow toilets have
um conservative washers etc etc there
hasn't been any adjustment in regards to
that no because that's one of those
things you can't control you know over
the years we used to consider a
reduction for compost oil it's a
gas-fired toilets many years after that
people would use those types of
facilities in shortly after they'd be
ripped out and they'd put in a flush
toilet so I mean the alternatives to a
regular flush toilet depending on
whether it's two liters a day and in the
old days it was like two gallons a day
as you well know and so the issue is is
there's been many people that have
looked at Alternatives but after they
have to maintain them and use them they
go away
thank you Mr Pelletier and it's
wonderful to have you here
if I understand your function or you
also oversee drinking water that's
correct okay so I'd like to start there
if I could so drinking water
uh on a large subdivision right now and
citing a well getting you you have to
start with the developer has to get
permission from the state to put a well
in where the well is going to be and so
forth no issue with that the problem is
that it can routinely take up to a year
to get through that process on a longer
subdivision how do we streamline that I
understand I understand Staffing is an
issue in people working but that's
that's a huge hindrance for development
so how can we streamline that that's a
good question thanks well I think one of
the issues that if it's smaller than 20
gallons per day or 40 gallons per day
then you don't need to go through the
large groundwater withdrawal now under
the statutory requirement for a large
groundwater withdrawal which would be
over 40 gallons per minute then in fact
there's a Litany of issues that you have
to go through hydrogeologically to see
if in fact that well is going to be
productive number one number two will it
impact any wells around that given area
so the timing is more a constraint
that's created on the on the process to
afford the right that you have the
protective well radius that's not going
to affect adjacent properties so at the
end of the day if you get a large water
withdrawal which we don't see many
anymore just because of the cost you
know to do a large groundwater
withdrawal to pay a consultant or a
hydrogeologist you're probably looking
at a hundred thousand probably 150.
in the old days we used to see a lot of
what representative McConkey is talking
about Community Wells and what the
benefit of that was is that because it
was located in one central location the
developer could create smaller lots and
that was the whole premise Behind These
Community Water Systems as time has
progressed the the requirements the
federal requirements of the Safe
Drinking Water Act have put in so much
testing requirements and even today
you've all heard the boutique contamina
now pfas P4 a lot of people are
concerned about that if they've got a
community well then what's the cost of
treating it if you've got high arsenic
you got high manganese what's the cost
of treating it so most people now when
we look at new subdivisions are looking
for on-site Wastewater so if there is a
cost associated with treatment then it
will be borne by the individual lot only
not by a homeowners association so the
long and the short that's a long answer
to a short question is that I don't see
that process sharding up I don't believe
it's our review time that's holding that
up that what's taking the year to get a
large groundwater withdrawal is hiring a
consultant to do the work
if I could so
um I'll I'll come back to that so there
was a common practice for developers and
you would you had struck a chord on the
amount of testing and annual uh process
required for Community system we're
putting uh multiple Wells on one lot
and servicing each well not servicing
more than what nine units or ten units a
piece and then but then all of a sudden
the department and I don't believe it
was the Feds all of a sudden the
department started saying that when you
have three of those wells in one lot
then that bumps that up to become a
higher standard and I I believe that was
done by the department not done by the
feds and I'd like to see that return can
you comment on that yeah I think when
whenever you look at it you've got a
given well radius as you well know Wells
have a Zona contribution
so people would for years try and get
away from the lodge or groundwater
withdrawal permitting requirements by
placing free welds to come under the
Department's review of a public water
system you need 15 or more service
connections so what people were trying
to do was avoid that regulation and put
three different Wells assuming they were
based on nine units per day when we got
a Department of Justice opinion on that
that was just a way to try and get
around the standard so if you if you're
going to develop a community system and
you choose to put in three Wells and you
may need to because one well may only
get two gallons a minute one well maybe
a hundred gallons per minute in Bedrock
that's pretty unusual so the answer
representative mcconkey's question you
know under the guise of putting three
wells in one particular site to beat the
system was decided by the Department of
Justice that that's considered as one
load
thanks thank you for that as unaware of
the Department of Justice ruling if you
could provide that to the chairman I'd
certainly appreciate it under that
regulation two Wells on one lot is still
permissible which would be 18 units on
on one lot
excuse me on 18 units housing units
on two Wells
are you saying if they're in the same
site if the the same site then that in
fact is another approach to try and get
around the approval process I I'm not so
worried about getting around our our
mission is how can we streamline how can
we make development a more reasonable
cost with precautions so everyone comes
to us and I'm sorry am I okay to
continue so everyone comes to us as a
developer if you don't have Town
Watertown sewer we're not going to talk
to you so what 75 80 percent of our our
sep our septic systems are on private
land so how can we make those those
processes happen and I I would I would
think that you might be willing to have
a further conversation on on maybe some
of those water issues at another time
sure could I move on
septic systems and I certainly share Mrs
pelletier's point on holding tanks it's
it's a last resort and they mysteriously
always find a way to uh to leech out so
good people uh unfortunately going
forward don't have that ability to use
them
um we have for longer than you and I
have been involved in this
um Stone and pipe has been the Mainstay
of New Hampshire septic systems
but and then there was an evolution of
plastic products that came along whether
it be Enviro or infiltrator and so forth
and when they came along with some
research it was developed they showed
that uh unlike a stone and pipe system
they could have a much smaller footprint
and if it was a new system they no
longer had to be four feet above
seasonal high water and I'm sorry if I
lose some in the weeds they could get
down to 24 inches under X number of
gallons a day and then to 30 inches
when a septic system fails in in our
state the new standard
comes in that all septic systems now can
be 24 inches to 30 inches above seasonal
High Water by loading
I would suggest it's time and I
understand that you're going through
rules at this point in time that the
department adopt as soon as possible
permitting Stone and pipe to have a 24
inch to seasonal high water perhaps with
a six inch sand bed which other states
do and or 30 above a thousand gallons
and the reason and I know you're looking
into this the reason for the thousand
gallon
um threshold per system is because
nitrates and phosphates are generated
now I have to keep each field so far
apart but if we stay under a thousand
gallons a lot of those regulations I
think it's time that it's done and it
can be done I'm hoping
um
it can be done in your new rules in
whatever this committee could do towards
that again I would like a further
conversation
the
uh so a stone and pipe for less than a
thousand gallons a day
would handle
um what a four or four unit
um house four bedrooms
uh going into that it would become
efficient for a condo a duplex
multiple Fields placed around would
would you agree with my first premise on
that and is that something that might
happen in your newest uh rules yeah I'm
not sure it's going to happen in new
rules but I I couldn't agree with you
more I think for years the technologies
that we've looked at and I'll go back to
the early years of just drink drinking
water treatment we know historically
that the sand under the bottom of the
bed or the original soil depending on
the soil type is carrying the load for
treatment so I would agree with you that
at this point in time it's time for us
to get through the
the change to include Stone and pipe
depending on if you have six inches of
sand underneath it because that's
carrying the load the sand as you well
know is what's treating it if you've got
a native soil that's effective in
treating then we don't worry so much
about six inches of sand the Innovative
Technologies that have come about over
the years Embrace of on testing as you
know they test in the mass
testing center to look at how effective
it is to a conventional system and
because number one maybe there's a lot
more air that moves through it which it
makes the bacteria aerobic instead of
anaerobic the digestion is much quicker
and much more thorough
with stone and and pipe I think back in
the old days we always used to have a
vent on one end of the other to move air
through you know aerobic digestion is so
much more efficient than anaerobic
so I would agree with you that I think
it's time that we try and take some time
and sit down and look at
giving the same benefits to Stone and
pipe I see a lot of people going back to
Stone and pipe a lot of people on having
good luck with the Innovative
Technologies for whatever reason whether
it be bed preparation or the type of
sand or you know pick a topic any topic
but
um yeah I I would not shy away from that
I think that's a good thought
representative I'm going to let you go
but it seems like
um you were the committee should put
together suggestions on rule changes for
Des and that could be part of our
recommendation thank you keep going one
final
so
um being in being in the industry
um and talking about some of the
Innovative products and they may not be
lasting as long and one of the
advantages of stone and pipe was the
large voids the large side of the field
taking care of perk rates and so forth I
I see on a regular basis phone calls at
least two to three times a week failed
septic systems I just bought the house I
didn't take the time to do a inspection
and now I'm facing a twenty thousand
dollar liability yep every day of the
week talking consoling people and so
forth so I'm I'm wondering if we as a
committee could keep an eye on uh
questions coming back uh talking about
for developers if if they were to be
permitted to use common Wells and so
forth and they were to put their their
subdivision smaller subdivisions or
groups of subdivisions
using condo regulations so that there
was a common fund that stayed in place
for Replacements and maintenance of
septics if that would be uh possibly a
good idea also
well I think you know if you look at to
me one of the biggest problems we have
whether it be water or Wastewater is
homeowner associations it is tough to
get everybody on the same page
especially if they're looking at a 20
000 or 30 or 40 000 price tag you know
I'm dealing with one right now and
bottle it big issue half of the
homeowners understand they need to do
well the other half don't want to pay
for it so
historically I think one of the cleaner
ways to do this is there ought to be a
statutory requirement when people file
condo agreements with the secretary of
state that they in fact have to create a
contingency fund so when something goes
awry whether it be on the water side of
the Wastewater side that people aren't
fighting because now all of a sudden
they're HOAs go up from 150 a month to
500.
you know and I think so you raise a good
point I I think historically in my
career homeowners associations for the
Lion's Share are a problem
um because you get new people to buy in
they're not diligent you know I would
like to see if something made a lot of
sense that it would be a statutory
requirement that when a property is sold
when you're talking about disclosure
then it ought to be required to have a
licensed designer
inspect the system to see if in fact
it's viable
you know what happens today is you know
Mark many people
just want to get in and buy they're not
diligent we see it with docs we see it
with breakwaters we see with septic
systems we see it with welds that get a
half a gallon a minute people come in
they get five kids that welds can't
support it so you know I think on the
real estate side or transfer side there
ought to be a lot more requirements that
diligence is followed you know so people
are not buying a pig in a poke
thank you Mr Pelletier and thank you for
the Indulgence committee
representative Rudy
Mr chairman yeah we've seen over the
last few years a big problem people
buying without inspections a huge
problem and very closely
but a follow-up to what we just talked
about
if we're in an association and say I
want to buy a unit in the association
you're suggesting that
an engineer take a look at the system to
make sure that that system is good or
the you know the tie-ins are there and
what's on my property is it's good okay
is that what you meant just just the
part that I'm purchasing well depending
on there is is we've just talked about
there are multiple ways that homeowners
get involved some have homeowner
associations for road maintenance
rubbish removal
but may have on-site on lot septic
systems there are those homeowner
associations that have a community
system where they may have a leech feel
it handles the Wastewater load from five
units and then the next five units have
a field somewhere else on that property
so depending on the Comfort level one
would have of buying a piece of property
in
on-site is pretty straightforward you
know if I'm going to spend half a
million dollars to buy a private lot on
light septic I mean I don't I want to go
in with eyes wide open you know so
what's the report they may go in and
have a well now as you well know one of
the common contaminants today is arsenic
you know there are some people that
don't believe in treatment they got
arsenic they'll drink it or they get
some one spout potable water where they
treat it somebody comes in with a larger
family and all of a sudden they choose
to test their water which a lot of
people don't do today and they find out
yikes my arsenics well above the
standard well now they could be in for
ten thousand dollar ticket to treat that
arsenic because they don't want to drink
it whereas it may not have been an issue
for the previous owner so there are a
lot of nuances that come up when you buy
a piece of property whether it be in a
homeowner association or just the
private house on a given lot in your
particular town so
the recommended issue here is one has to
be diligent there are two key paths to a
shot of the lead-based paint and all the
other stuff but from the environmental
side on our side on the water side there
are two key components that cut could
cost one a lot of money that would be
waste water like representative McConkey
said septic systems today are costing
somewhere around 20 grand 25 grand for a
four bedroom house you know if you go in
your system fails because you weren't
diligent you didn't have it inspected
then that's on you
you go in and you don't test you have
your water tested for parameters that
are concerned whether it be nitrogen
whether it be manganese whether it be
arsenic then that's on you so those are
the things that can go awry and when we
get people to call up and they're beside
themselves you know and we have no
recourse you know if they bought
something in weren't diligent about
doing an evaluation of what they were
actually buying that there's nothing we
can do for them
yeah thank you Mr chairman there's a
follow-up if I'm if I'm going to buy a
property and I I have to have my water
tested
and say there's five people on the well
and then my neighbor wants to sell his
house my neighbor's going to have to
have it tested
should the association
um
take my my test and hold it and it's
good for a certain period of time you
think
for the five units
or
we're an Uncharted Territory so tell me
what you think
um but if I'm going to pay for a test
why should you have to pay for a test no
and if it's a community well and that's
a small community well and I wouldn't
even call it 20 units that well is not
regulated by us so if in fact it's five
units and it's not in the public
drinking water program if you were smart
and diligent went out and took a test I
would think if somebody else came in
bought a next unit if the if there is an
association for this five unit cluster
or whatever it might be then that should
be a valid water sample
you know but I would say water
especially in Bedrock Wells over years
is demand increases the the constituents
may change so it's not a bad thing where
every year or two that you should
certainly check it but anyone that buys
a structure of any kind that does not
look and see what their water quality is
or their well
is not good
thank you
um anybody else representing Keller
hi thank you
um so you talked a little bit about the
Innovative
um Technologies for septic
um
and
I I'm interested in how
um
um I guess uh complicated that process
is
um for the you know the person that does
it the first time for this type of
system and then how does that Innovative
technology like
um
like I guess proof to the department get
turned into just the standard
um like we've we've looked at this
before we don't have to look at it every
time for an Innovative technology we've
looked at this technology before so it's
no longer Innovative it's just
uh technology that is you know that we
have rules for I guess set up yeah good
question I think when we approve an
Innovative technology that is approved
in perpetuity unless we see over a trend
that let's say over a year or two we see
a massive amount of failures then we
would re-evaluate that technology and
try and find out but let's say we
approve system X as an Innovative
technology that's approved so if you
used it and then two years later
somebody down the road wants to use it
that's an approved technology we don't
have to revisit it again the only time
we revisit Innovative Technologies that
we approve is if in fact we see an
anomaly in a number of failures so we
would then talk to the distributor or
the owner of that technology and say hey
what's the problem
you know what's going on but once it's
approved it's approved
thank you I like to follow up um the
with these Innovative Technologies are
you
um
are you calculating
um the
like Effectiveness versus the
other Technologies and how much water or
or
treatment they can actually produce and
therefore you know uh this size of
system is going to be able to treat four
houses and the four houses approved the
Eight houses approved at this you know
load et cetera et cetera
um
and and how well is that
um you know available to the public
about what things are approved what
options do they have versus
um or is that kind of incumbent on the
engineer to tell them or well I think
first of all as you may or may not know
all septic systems in New Hampshire
whether they're new failed Replacements
have to be submitted to the department
by a licensed designer that over the
years has been a great program because
there those people are well educated on
soil they know what they're looking at
and they can get in and get a design
whenever we approve an Innovative
technology that comes with books of
testing this done out of the mass
testing center in Massachusetts where
they can pair a new technology to a
stone and pipe system see what the
effectiveness of treatment is and that
in fact will dictate their height to
seasonal high water table depending on
the soil and also the amount of area
necessary to treat the appropriate waste
water load that's going to go there so
they may vary based on what the and I'm
talking a lot of testing to see what
kind of Effectiveness they are what kind
of area is necessary what kind of height
above seasonal high water table will in
fact adequately tweet treat whatever
Wastewater is going to be generated for
that particular utility so they may vary
in square footage or what area you need
but it would all be based and premised
on what the testing looked like and how
efficient and effective was it in
treating the Wastewater
thank you
um so so with these books of data
um that sounds expensive to get a new uh
Innovative uh
technology approved
um
is
do we have to do our own
um you said like Boston or Massachusetts
or something is doing the testing or is
that
um is like
let's say a new technology goes to
Boston they say I want to get approved
they give them all this data and they
say here's here test this can is that
that single place able to like approve
and show the data and then like many
states accept that that data so that
they can approve them or
um are we saying no we have to get our
own testing requirements for for that
yeah no we have parameters that we
expect to see in the testing program and
the mass testing center has that data so
they will compare this Innovative
technology to Stone and pipe basically
is what they do those reams of testing
the parameters that are done they will
submit that data or the applicant that
wants us to approve their technology
we'll submit the results of that data
and if the numbers we don't re-evaluate
it again if this is what that testing
center tells us and they're very good at
what they do then in fact we would base
our Innovative permit on the data that
we see from that information
all right I have a couple questions
do you need to go again okay just
um how many
uh
uh Innovative Technologies are getting
approved like um is it like one a year
one every five years one every ten years
one every 15 years
depends on the given year sometimes it
may be one or two a year and then we may
not see a new technology coming in for
three years
you know it it basically is based on the
entrepreneurship of what people want to
do
okay to um piggyback off that do you
when when a technology is approved do
you go through all the administrative
rules and try to update them depending
on new technology in the field yeah we
will when when it comes in we will in
fact post on the website technologies
that are viable to be permitted by a
licensed designer okay and if the
technology would
um
make it
easier for would the technology make it
so that you're able to LAX up on the
rules a little bit like make them less
stringent maybe with new technology
that's what I'm wondering is like how
often are these rules looked at and
Revisited depending on like developments
in the field what we look at is when
somebody comes in with an Innovative
technology that we've approved then we
don't have to update the rules that you
can submit a licensed designer will
submit it they know we've approved the
technology we will look at the
parameters that were that approval was
based on and move you through the
process
and for the record when we get a septic
system
application in we have electronic
permitting at the department now for
septic systems as representative
McConkey knows it's generally a one-day
turnaround
you know and what happens is all of our
technical staff have two screens the
applicant will submit an application pay
it online and you can see on a screen
what the design is if there's some
issues you can respond in an email
electronically the designer can correct
it submit new plans electronically and
that still may get out the door in a day
or two so the process is greatly it's
probably
one of the best systems in maybe in the
country if not certainly in New England
so Ted how often
are DS's rules Revisited our rules are
good for eight years but we do do them
shorter than eight years depending on if
there are some biting issues that we
really need to address and I think we're
we're we had some legislation passed
this year for Wells that were installed
prior to 89 so that's going to be a a
great benefit to people that have
pre-existing 89 Wells so but as far as
rules if there's something that we see
continually is having a difficult time
with the public and with us as well we
will
go into a roommaking process as you know
rulemaking is a six to eight month
process it's very time consuming
and so what we try and do is we'll we'll
look at issues that concern us a concern
the public and we all agree a
constituency in ourselves agree then we
may let those build so when we do a rule
making it's not for one item it may be
for multiple because rulemaking is very
involved
okay and my last question is regarding
Renovations is there when a property is
renovated or is there anything that Des
has to approve or permit or once that
once the building is built yep there's
nothing else they should have a
operational approval for if it's an
online septic system and unless they're
all during the sewage load meaning
you're renovating your building and you
have a state approval for a two-bedroom
house you renovate and you put in
another two bedrooms you've got to come
back to us to make sure that that site
can handle the Wastewater load for an
additional two bedrooms okay so that
that would be really the only reason if
you increase the bedroom limit
yes okay
if I might or if you get a commercial
establishment let's say you run a space
and you go in or you bought a little uh
coffee shop let's say and you had like
five seats and three employees and all
of a sudden you buy it the building's
large enough you now have 50 seats that
comes to us as well okay representative
Wallace
thank you
are we we're looking to kind of
streamlines and maybe not relax the
rules but make them a little bit more
workable for developers are we still
bound to be compliant with the federal
title V is that no that's Massachusetts
God knows we don't want Title Five no
exactly
excellent
representative
thank you
um
seemed to me
um when we were talking before that you
um require
certain systems to be
um like let's say the minimum General is
four bedrooms
um
when you're approving a system whether
that be a four bedroom or eight bedroom
or whatever if the
um if they
let's say had an eight bedroom septic
system approved but they only Built four
bedrooms and then they built four more
bedrooms it would still be within the
the
capacity that the the the the septic
um
the approval was for right and so they
wouldn't have to come back for that
additional four bedrooms if they did
that 20 years later they would just have
to do it if they exceeded what the
approved number of bedrooms or wait load
was and how would that
um be
I guess
um kind of on the same vein for the
commercial ones how would you do that
wouldn't you be saying hey the system
can handle you know
20 occupants you know a day or whatever
and
you would only revisit that when you
went above that 20 occupants or would
you just do it whenever they changed
from five people to 10 people even
though they're both under 20. yeah so
let's start from the beginning of this
process so you've got a particular lot
let's say and you've got a construction
approval for eight bedrooms right so we
go out you install that design it could
support eight bedrooms we would come out
and inspect it
assuming everything was right you'd get
an operational approval for eight
bedrooms so now you decide as the owner
that right now in fact you can only do
four bedrooms that approval you may have
to go to the town you get a building
permit you show me construction or your
operational approval so going through
the town process to get a permit if you
show a valid operational approval for
eight bedrooms then there should be no
problems with building the next four
same thing commercially it's all about
loading per site
okay I'm one last question yes so you
were you were talking about having these
multiple Wells
um and being kind of avoiding the
community well
um thing so it seems to me that if you
had these let's say you had 20 units
um each having uh two different well or
you know two Well Servicing these 20
units
um
it seems like
if you want you could do you know two
two Wells or three Wells or four Wells
servicing each 10 units but
if you would be essentially
incentivizing those
um the property owner to
um make each of those 10 units be its
own site instead of to avoid being a
community well they would just
divide those into multiple sites instead
of having one site with three
or four Wells is that
um like the your understanding of how
someone would get around that that
Community well thing without being in
violation of any rules because
technically they are a different site
because of the the determination that
came out of the doj that in fact is a
way around the law all Wells have what
we call a zone of contribution so when
you look at a particular site that has a
particular aquifer whether you've got
shallow Wells or Bedrock Wells they are
all taking they're tapping the same
straw
the same straw so when you look at it so
you've got three different Wells to try
and get by this 10 10 and 10 because the
community well once you service 15 or
more you're into testing requirements
which in fact should be done you know so
to me that's not an appropriate approach
it's getting people around the system to
make sure on a rigorous testing schedule
on a monthly or a quarterly whatever the
schedule is that people are afforded the
luxury of having safe drinking water so
for someone to come in and try and beat
the system that's just not a good thing
and that's why if you're trying to add
multiple Wells to get 10 10 and 10
that's the same straw
test
okay
representative McConkey
thank you once again adus uh the
legislature and Department worked hard
attorney general everyone else so I want
to add a unit uh to an existing site in
Adu and I believe the the ruling came
through that I don't have to build that
septic system a new septic system for
that purpose but in the event that the
Adu or the house fails then it will be
billed at that time
how how has that worked out to date uh
we don't see a lot of the Adu stuff but
again a lot of it we may not know unless
something failed but what happens is you
well know being a licensed designer and
a pretty good one actually I mean he
paid me 20 bucks to say that but okay
but he and his son both do good work but
the point being is they come in and it's
all about if we go back a little bit to
what kind of site loading can a
particular Apostle handle
so what he's referencing let's say that
you've got a three bedroom house it's
got a construction approval you get an
operational approval and but the lot
could support four bedrooms but whenever
the house was built they decided that's
what they needed three-bedroom house
somebody comes in a licensed designer
they do a plan that shows that in fact
by adding an Adu that the site can still
handle the waste water load that will be
generated from the existing three
bedrooms to the Adu Adu Wastewater load
as he said
you're good to go but a year down the
road if that system fails we know that
you can support the four bedrooms of
five or whatever it's going to be and
you would have to install that to
replace the field system so it's been
pretty effective I think thank you so
are you saying that if an Adu is
approved
that's more than what the current septic
system could hold what would you approve
one
like do you have to
approve one if you know if you wanted to
add an Adu with one more bedroom that
system could only hold and Adu would be
approved if somebody like a licensed
designer does the analytical work to
show that the site in fact can handle
the additional Wastewater loaders can be
generated by that Adu you're good to go
okay
now that means you'd get a construction
approval you don't have to build it but
it clearly shows that you can now
support four or five bedrooms on that
site whatever it's going to be and
you're good to go if the system fails
that plan that shows the loading and the
system size for five bedrooms needs to
be installed okay
all right representative yukela one last
question
then we're done we we were arguing a
little bit about your response um your
your response to my last question was in
fact it is legal for you to have your
the three separate sites
because you actually said that that the
requirement is per site
right and so if you subdivide that and
now have three different homeowners
association technically that's three
different people okay so can you clarify
that a little bit I don't mean to cut
you off
when you talk about sight if you're
talking about three separate parcels
all right so you've got three five acre
sites or whatever the size is and you've
got five units on that site and you've
got a well that's fine
but if you've got a site the definition
of sight versus Lord is very different
so if you've got a site where you've got
15 units in that one parcel has 15 units
on it and you drill three welds in
service five five and five that's not
legal
so the parcel and and so I don't
understand you're saying the lot and
parcel are different lot in sight lot in
sight so what so the parcel
mm-hmm the parcel and site are the same
right what what are you trying to to let
me make this say science is different
you've got a deeded site or lot whatever
you want to call it deeded parcel right
that's five acres it's by deed okay it's
per deed okay that's that's so so you
could just subsidize your 15 acre
property into three deeded properties of
five acres and then you could do your
your yeah that's what I said you could
see no you it sounded maybe that maybe
that was my misunderstanding but when
you would I feel like we're getting
caught up yeah yeah we're getting yeah
we're getting caught up in the weeds
all right thank you very much you're
welcome for uh giving us more questions
answers no man for the record no I think
this kind of conversation is really good
and I think it's one of those things
that when whenever uh against changing
laws that make more sense I mean rules
and uh I think representative McConkey
can contest that we've had many
stakeholder groups where we listen to
people and it's a brain meld you know we
don't know everything there's a lot of
information that we glean not only for
septic systems but all of the water
stuff that we do so we never shy away
from people getting in a room and having
a conversation about
what makes sense so if the committee
wants to send over something like
representative McConkey suggested about
things that may white might want to
consider then I would never shy away
from getting stakeholders involved and
say what do you think
what do you think what's the approach
how can we get there I think the stone
and pipe thing to me is kind of a
no-brainer we know that the Sands
carrying the load that's what's treating
Wastewater I've said for several years
now the NFL Trowbridge is my new lrm guy
I think we're looking at
justification that says that stone and
pipe ought to be treated like other
stuff
great thank you very much well thanks
for the invite and don't hesitate to
call I'd always I'm always willing to
participate in a conversation that makes
sense for everybody thank you Randy
yeah we're gonna move right in okay
Joe
sorry I didn't have time to come out and
greet you but you see we're running a
little late so it's no problem I know I
just want to thank you for taking the
time from your very busy schedule to
come up and talk to us
um Joel witcher's uh engineer from
Manchester and uh for years he's been my
go-to guy if I ever need a question
answered or whatever
he's got a vast knowledge of most of the
planning boards and zoning boards around
at least from the middle part of the
state south that I know of but whenever
I have a question he's the first call I
make and he really knows what's going on
and he knows what's going on in every
city and town around so Joe we're we're
formed to see if we can't uh streamline
the process into being able to get some
affordable housing
time is a valuable commodity that keeps
the clock rolling I know and uh
that's why we asked you to come to maybe
give us some insight on what some of the
different communities do and maybe uh
something we can do at the state level
to speed the process along so I'm just
going to let you run with whatever you
want to talk about
oh
thank you okay so uh first of all thank
you for having me my name is Joe wicker
and as a representative baruti said
um I own I'm a self-employed land
surveyor out of Manchester so I think
I've been on my own since uh 91. I think
I was licensed in 90 I'm a licensed
septic designer as well
um
you know and when I talked to Ben we had
some conversations about
um about this issue right so in in
Manchester I'm also a member of the
housing commission and
um you know we're we're seeing the same
things in in Manchester that everybody's
seeing so you know I think the best
example I can kind of come up with to
try to illustrate what I think we're up
against is
back in 93 or 94 my firm
did a little three four lot subdivision
in the city
for some reason the owner never recorded
the mylar and 20 something years later
we get a phone call saying hey you know
we need do you have the my the original
mylar we don't
so we have to work with the city and try
to figure out how to
kind of resolved this because it was
previously approved so it's just sort of
a matter of just how we how we take care
of the the details of it but I started
laughing and I and I brought the plan
when I brought the plan down to staff
and I was showing them you know in 1993
or 94 we showed the boundary lines we
showed the buildings a few notes it was
kind of straightforward in 2023
you know we have like a dozen notes we
have to show topography buildable area
building boxes we have to have a
building area table we have to subtract
out areas of steep slopes we have to
take out areas of easements existing and
proposed right and all these items you
know take a consultant time so therefore
they add on to the cost and you know the
bigger item in my world is a lot of
these things
will void out a lot right so if you you
know the simple example is in Manchester
which is the one I'm most familiar with
you know they have a buildable area
requirement so if you're in a zone that
requires 7 500 square feet that 7 500
has to be fully buildable
and you know so they Define buildable as
anything under a 25 slow which you know
in buildable areas and topography 25
slope that's probably not necessarily
the most unreasonable item to say
except for if you're in a city and
you're on Municipal sewer and water and
you have a little band that's three foot
tall
and it's only 10 foot wide or five foot
wide
now all of a sudden I can't make that
lot work so I have to go to the Zoning
Board of adjustment and I have to say
listen
I have 7 500 square feet but it's not 7
500 square foot buildable by definition
so therefore I have to go get a variance
before I can go to the planning board
um
you know in a lot of the towns in the
cities
you know you could say they're trying
and and I probably believe some are but
I'm not necessarily convinced that that
translates to boards right so you may
have politicians and in groups and
commissions and task force and
everything that say Yep this is a
problem and this is what we need to work
with
but when we go to a planning board or a
zoning board we don't necessarily get
the same response you know and so we did
a subdivision
um on a parcel of land that was about 22
Acres
our role in it was to just subdivide the
parent tract off you know to subdivide
the 22-acre track from the parent tract
and then it was going to get sold and
then further develop but the owner
didn't want to develop it at this time
so you know to to help with the pricing
and everything we did a concept we said
okay listen 22 Acres with these
frontages this minimum area we came up
with 33 lots and out of those 33 Lots I
think the only waivers we would need
were for Centerline Road radius on on
the road system
so we meet with the town and we say okay
you know this is what we have for a
concept and we get told well
we're not going to waive the Centerline
Road radius requirement you know they
had a 300 foot radius
uh road which in a in a rural area that
that makes sense because you don't want
a lot of sharp turns but we were coming
off of an area that was gridded out that
had 90 degree intersections we were
coming off of an area with 90 degree
intersections
so you're saying okay well would you
give me anything you know would you
would you support any kind of waiver and
they we go back and forth we kind of
come up with a number we go back we we
rework the concept we come up with 31 I
think we lost a couple Lots
there's a buyer for the property we go
for the development we go to the
planning board to subdivide that land
and one of the last
words of wisdom we were given from the
planning board chair was well you should
tell the buyer that that's two debts
right so if you're thinking about it and
you say okay well if I have 22 acres and
if I have half acre zoning
the simple mass is 44 but then you have
to back out your road some of your steep
slopes and things like that
but
you know to say that 31 is too isn't is
is too many you know that it doesn't
make sense to me because I think what we
should be encouraging is to we come off
of areas all the time where the existing
developments are more
uh more compact than what the current
ordinance requires and so those areas
should be the ones that you know we
should get waivers for you should get
variances for it'll match the existing
areas
um and and then therefore we get more
housing units right if the developer is
Happy the town in theory should be happy
um the neighbors will necessarily never
be happy but you know that's part of
living next to a large undeveloped
property that you don't own
you know we
we do multiple projects where we come in
and we see we try to propose a a lot
that's undersized or lots that are
undersized or more units that are
allowed by the current ordinance
and you know our running joke is the
people that are complaining are
typically on lots that are smaller than
our on the average lot size we're
proposing with lost Frontage and more
debts so you're looking at them going
well but how does it reduce the value of
your property because it's bigger than
yours and and that seems to get to get
lost so
um
you know I can
as I got older I guess you start looking
back so I started off in the 80s and in
the 80s You could argue that there were
probably some developments and plans
that weren't necessarily fantastic ones
and I think that is part of what drove
you know the seven 60s 70s and 80s kind
of everybody did this certain thing you
had the Boom in the mid 80s and after
that I you know we noticed where things
started tightening up right and when
they started tightening up everybody
came up with different systems to kind
of reduce the density in all these other
items and some of those might have been
warranted and they might have been based
in fact but a lot of them the way their
interpreted or employed
it doesn't necessarily work out that way
you know like Renee was here and
um
you know we get we go to towns that have
soil based zoning so if you have uh
on-site well and septic you know instead
of having a 200 foot of Frontage two
acre zoning you could have on-site um
soil based zoning So based on either the
high intensity soil survey or the soils
something mapping
um site-specific mapping you end up with
the new higher soil scientists they
break out the soil types you do kind of
a weighted average and you can figure
out what your what Your lot size should
be right and all right that's based in
science to a degree so you'd say that
that probably isn't the worst thing we
could look at
but a lot of towns will
still have a minimum and that minimum
will be over what the size is that the
numbers would so you sort of lose the
advantage of soil based zoning so soil
based zoning is if you have good soils
you should have more units if you have
poor soils you should have less units
but if the town has a requirement that
you have to stay at a certain Frontage
and area
and even though by Zone by soils you
could do two two units in there you know
we don't get the we don't come up with
the density that that would be there by
right
um
you know and I had talked to you know
we've gone back and forth with this on
uh you know on different groups that I'm
in and and how we how you get there and
how you can make it better and things
like that so you know at the end of the
day I think I'm a Believer in local
zoning I'm not necessarily to a point
where I'd want to see say State zoning
because I don't think you could Zone
Manchester the same way you could Zone
Hillsboro New Hampshire they're they're
just different so you have to allow but
what frustrates me is when I was on uh
before I got on the Housing Commission
of Manchester
you know we did an analysis or a a guess
an educated guess right a swag we came
up with and said Yep this is where this
is our number and so you know Manchester
has roughly 51 000 units it was
projected that we had a half a percent
vacancy rate and average or ideal would
be a three to five percent vacancy rate
so if you took straight numbers
you know we would need an increase of
roughly 4 000 uh you know uh to get to a
four percent four and a half percent
increase that's roughly a two thousand
two thousand units right well Manchester
has
I think we're we're approaching 2 000
units that are either in the queue
approved or in construction
um we still have half a percent vacancy
rate
so we have a half a percent vacancy rate
because
some of the surrounding communities you
know Manchester May approve 1900 but the
surrounding communities might approve
50. so a lot of those people from the
surrounding communities as they get
older and want to kind of downsize will
come to the city which you know is is
not a bad thing it's a good thing but
if the communities that aren't
staying up with what they need to for an
increase in numbers you know if there
were a way to incentivize that or
somehow
um make it work better and and we went
back and forth is you know could you
localize
the waiting list right so if a if a
community provides a hundred you know
100 affordable units my understanding of
the current system is you still go on
the master list and you get prioritized
on the master list and then you get
assigned to the unit as it comes open
well would there be a way to
bump your priority if you're a resident
of this community and the community has
provided a hundred units of affordable
units right you could still take some
people but if we could figure a way to
to incentivize communities to to look at
it that way that their people could stay
in their communities if they chose to
you know I think that would be a good
thing so I was trying to keep my initial
uh Spiel short so I'd be happy to answer
any questions you might have
okay thank you
um any questions
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um you were talking about
soil based
um zoning lot requirement or size
requirements
um do you think that that is
um
a way that
that is a good way of moving the state
forward do you think that these you know
say two acre or five acre just generic
lot requirements is appropriate or and
we should be sticking with that as a
state or should we be moving more
towards like uh soil based zoning where
where the it's not a hard and fast rule
but looking at the site for the minimum
uh that is allowable
so I think if we're you know if you're
going to go with science then soil based
zoning is the closest we have
because that's based on the carrying
capacity of the soils and you know lots
that have great soils are going to be a
smaller size lots that have some
Wetlands steep slopes Sledge they're
going to be larger
um so I I do like it but you know my
problem
has always been you have communities
that are anywhere from 80 to 95 percent
built out the majority of them are built
out on either 150 or 200 foot of
Frontage an acre and a half two acre
zoning
we come in now and we say okay we're
going to go to soil based zoning you
know how do we get any increase in
density
and I think you know for new
developments yeah it'd be great if if
the town would accept it or if they
would allow some kind of cluster
development with an equation to figure
out your buildable area based on the
actual property instead of just a number
that the zoning ordinance came up to
because you know I'm not I'm not a
believer in that zoning is
um
was totally a stop growth measure but
I've been around long enough to live
through two of the boom bust cycles and
we had growth management ordinance in
the mid twos that were you know we we
had to we could only give out two
permits a year because if we gave out
more than two permits a year we were
going to overwhelm schools and in 2023
just about every Community I know of has
somewhere between a 10 and 20 reduction
in school population
right so if we had we would have had
more units out there I mean you know
personally we I was a a partner in a
development
um and you know you build the
infrastructure but you can only sell two
lots a year it's hard to make a lot of
money out of that
right so you're not going to get you
know you're not going to get it now in
today's world which is similar to what
it was in six and seven you know you
might have somebody that's willing to
take that risk on the hope that they're
going to get there but you know luckily
we don't have as many communities with
growth management ordinances anymore
they're at least that way
okay
all right thank you Joe
um of all the units that are approved
now in Manchester do you know how many
are affordable housing units
I think Manchester is about
375 ish
out of the I think it's about 375 out of
the um
out of the 1900 or so and and why
what incentive is there for someone to
build affordable housing what can we
offer somebody to want to go down that
route
so I guess in the Manchester example I
think probably half to 60 percent of
those units are one project with a
developer that has a different model
that I've never I had never seen until
this where it's based on all tax credits
and things like that and all the units
are affordable right and so that is and
Mr Dupont is probably much better verse
to explain the intricacies of that than
I am but for me
you know I think I'm a Believer in the
way that if we're gonna
if we're going to see more units you
have to incentivize it right so margins
are
margins are hard right now because of
expiring costs and things like that so
if we could you know my theory was
always in the city which you know we're
I'm the most involved in if we could
come up with like a Redevelopment zone
so you take areas of the community that
are sort of blighted that need some
Redevelopment and you say okay here's
what we want to see you know the current
zoning is X
we're going to give you X plus 25 but in
out of that 25 percent you have to give
a proportion a portion of that 25
percent have to be affordable right and
then the developer wins you get some
extra market rate units you get some
affordable units and the community wins
because we get more affordable units and
then you know if you take certain
communities a larger more developed
communities you know we are going to
have gentrification going on you know
we're going to have in a perfect world
or not perfect world however you want to
phrase it that you're going to have
areas that are
underutilized and sort of blighted now
that are going to be redeveloped when
those areas are redeveloped we're going
to lose some of the naturally affordable
uh the natural occurring affordable
housing so you know now we become into
the you know can we come up with a
system to have the the number of units
um that we're building or we're the new
number units can it replace the existing
units we're losing right and it's going
to be I think that's a big ass to
replace that existing number in my
position has been I think we have to
accept that the number may be a hair
less but the quality of the units will
be substantially better
so no one will be living in
um you know a Triple Decker that hasn't
been updated in 70 years and and has all
these uh faults with it they'd be living
in new housing you know and and they'd
be have similar amenities to the people
that they're living next to that are in
a market rate unit
okay
um thank you for that
um what about a community Manchester
needs housing so to give them incentives
is one thing but what about a community
that
um doesn't want a lot of
apartment dwellings or condos is there
anything you can think of to give them
an incentive to allow it
you know
I think at the end of the day
the only way I said my theory would be
you prioritize you you change the
priority of the list and I don't know if
that breaks some kind of federal
guideline State guidelines or whatever
but somehow there should be a way that a
community that produces a certain number
of affordable units can kind of keep a
percent of those units for the residents
right that way it's the only way that
um they're going to kind of personalize
this you know we did a project
um where we tried to do 14 units sort of
like modular housing and it was similar
to another modular housing or
manufacture housing Park that was less
than 400 feet away
we were denied the waiver so instead of
having 14
modular housing units we ended up with
six stick built units
so the difference being those six stick
built units are probably going to be
High fours to high fives versus if we
had the 14 modulars maybe they would
have been 354 right and you know people
will say well it doesn't sound like a
huge difference but I think if you're
the person trying to buy it it is and we
actually had a person on the planning
board who supported it for that reason
they were looking for a house
and they they knew the numbers and they
were like hey you know if we give them
this it's going to help with that so
representative Conkey
um thank you sir for being here you
bring a
you bring an area of discussion that I'm
not usually accustomed to being the
urban environment
I'm wondering if I if I heard you
correctly in some of in some of your
properties that you've designed for
built on talking about minimal lot size
and excludes uh parts parts of that
property that have a slope of 25 percent
or more
um there there was a time
when 25 slope was uh was a difficult
item to deal with uh Construction and
building and now 25 is not that's I'm
thinking of infill lots especially uh so
I'm wondering if and I understand and I
have you know 15 18 years on zoning
boards and everything else that you know
local is always better and it's it's
hard to get even the people sitting at
our table to agree that the state should
mandate but
perhaps perhaps we could come up with
some legislation that was that was
recommending
um
that in situations within Phil
if you meet these requirements you've
got septic handled whether it's on-site
or off-site municipal or whatever if the
slope of the lot was not a deterrent to
the building if you were mindful of
existing neighborhood density I'm paying
attention to what you're saying here and
these items then it should be considered
as opposed to Shelby I'm just thinking
if you get some language out there that
we could get support for it might it
might get some of those towns that are
saying no at least the opportunity to
say if there's people on their boards
you know maybe we could go in that
direction
think we would have any merits sir yeah
I mean I so we're working on one now
where the the local requirement is 15
percent
right to me 15 is to say it's
non-buildable silly
and especially in New Hampshire where
you're going to have you know rugged
terrain it's so you know if we adopted
Des rule 35 percent and up was
considered non-buildable everything
underneath maybe you can give the towns
some leeway that they could do a
weighted average that if you're above 25
percent it's only 80 percent it only
counts as 80 percent instead of a
hundred right yeah that would I think
that has some merits
um you know the
there's the time my argument when we
talk to a client my line is always
listen it's their home court all we're
doing is playing by their rules so they
have all the cards the best we can do is
react and you have towns that can
control it through zoning ordinances and
regulations and waivers you have towns
that have
um Wetland setbacks that you know will
cost you two to five thousand dollars to
appeal
and I think we had one town where we
went in and you know we are we argue
that we should get a reduction in the
waiver and we were told the the
Conservation Commission members said
well you know we don't really agree with
your consultant's report
because the Consultants always say it
could be reduced
and as I've gotten older I tend to have
less of a filter
and so when when it was said I looked at
them and said well yeah 125 feet is the
silly requirement so why to get me to 75
which is all we were asking for you
should approve it but local
municipalities don't like that because
it doesn't fit what they perceive they
their Community should be I mean I think
if you could if you could standardize
Wetland setbacks based on science if you
could standardize slopes
um I think those items would still give
the town some input that you're not
we're not taking away their their
jurisdiction over their town
does anyone else have questions
representative
um can you you you you talk about how
um
maybe
incentivizing these
um affordable units and I assume that
you're meaning
um affordable by
by
um not
that the house is built affordable but
that it's agreed to be a s rented or
sold at an affordable rate for a certain
amount of time right but
um that those go to a certain residence
inside of the
um Community I don't see how
um the board the planning board
um or the zoning board
or the mayor or anyone
would be make a decision
for more
um you know units because they are going
to the population
that is already living there can you
explain how you would see that as an
incentive to those Regulators to allow
those those units to be built more
um without hindrance I guess based on
your view that they would be going to
the people that are already living in
the community
we could try I'm not sure it'll work I
think the problem is
The Regulators aren't the people on the
board
right so I think if we went to the Town
Council the board of Mayor and Alderman
and said listen if we approve this if we
rewrite this zoning ordinance we're
going to hopefully get an additional X
number you affordable units per per year
right and I think
the majority of those units would either
end up being rentals or
maybe a condominium because from what
I've heard
when you try to manipulate the
affordable to fee ownership it becomes
problematic like I know Nashua has a
Nashville has a
inclusionary zoning ordinance right and
so we've I've talked just as part of my
work on the Housing Commission I've
talked to the National planner
and so one of the unforeseen issues
they've had is if you regulate the value
of a house your
reducing the income of that owner
because for most people their residence
is their main you know is their main
their largest asset so if you if you
stipulate that the house can only
increase at a certain percent and the
remainder has to be affordable you've
Defeated You've defeated them gaining
generational wealth to do it so I think
it has to be broken down that I'm not so
sure on fee ownership we're going to
have a lot of input but the hope would
be is for rentals maybe some
condominiums that you could and you know
would they agree to it you know I'm I'm
on the fence on that I mean it's the
only thing short of changing everything
around and saying this is what it is
everybody's going to follow the same
Rule and these are the numbers we're
going to have you know I I don't want to
see a situation where we do a project in
a planning board or a Housing Commission
or a zoning board can say we want X
percent of these units is Affordable
because I think what you'd see happening
is the remaining units are going to
basically subsidize the affordable units
and now what we've done is we've
increased the rents and the cost to the
other unit so somehow if we could break
it out into a system where
a lot of the infrastructure is already
being built but the developer is getting
more units
you know maybe there's a way to to make
that work better
great well thank you very much for
coming presenting to us I appreciate it
much appreciated thank you very much
all right so our next presentation is
from Red Oak Properties
I'm sorry I don't know your name could
you come up thank you thank you
um
you might just press the
how's that there we go is that good okay
thank you for for having me today my
name is Ron Dupont and I do I do want to
apologize upfront because I have even
less of a filter than Joe because I'm
older than Joe okay
um so I'm just gonna tell you
how it is and and my thoughts okay first
of all I think you should know some
something about me okay uh I'm a New
Hampshire native born raised my wife is
also uh we love the state uh we've been
to every tourist attraction that there
is probably three four five eight times
okay
um
we uh my wife and I both work in the
business uh I work hard I was in this
morning at seven o'clock and I have a
five o'clock meeting which is probably
gonna last a while
okay
um I own and I don't have a lot of
Partners I basically have one okay and I
own a little bit over 1800 Apartments
okay I've been doing this a while okay I
started with a three family home in
Hudson New Hampshire which I just sold
two three years ago
uh just built are probably one of the
coolest buildings in the state of New
Hampshire in downtown Manchester that
was uh what's the right word that I
should use okay but difficult
challenging frustrating I want to hit my
head against the wall and it probably
would have felt good okay
um I also started about five or six
years ago a single family home business
longest story my daughter got married to
this really hard working guy for from
Maine he's a real salt of the earth type
of guy Hands-On so we're building some
homes and I'm gonna hopefully at some
point talk about what Joe was actually
just talking about Nashua the
inclusionary zoning ordinance there I
have specific a specific example it's
happening right now it's hugely
frustrating
we don't think we're going to be able to
build 83 homes
exit one Nashua but I'm not I'm going to
start first on a few other things if if
that's okay
it's my fault
I have not been talking to my Alderman
enough
but I don't have time I'm running the
business
okay
um so
let's talk 409 Elm Street in man in
Manchester okay I started the building
process about six year year years ago
concerning zoning planning had a
neighbor who didn't
agree with what was happening I went for
three variances of which an attorney of
Joe's still here is it is it gone yeah
he's gone okay okay uh that Joe uses a
lot John John Cronin and John said these
are three very very very simple
variances okay so we we got all three
um the neighbor appealed all three it
took me to Superior Court okay it was
there
um and so slow down the project for by a
long time we just wrapped it up in the
past three or four months
okay a lot of construction issues but
but I'm not going to go there because of
the times that we are in lack of quality
lack of quality lack of quality in this
in the in this country amazes me amazes
me okay
um
so
one specific item there so eversource
okay after our request gave us a letter
that said we had consistent power it's
right on Elm Street it's what is it one
half a mile a mile from City Hall
okay beautiful okay went to the fire
department with that they said wonderful
so you don't have to have a generator
there hundred fifty thousand dollars and
and it takes up space and has to be
maintained I don't have to have a
generator so I just saved myself a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars I'm
pretty happy go to the go to the
planning department beautiful okay you
don't have to have a generator
okay then the State Fire Marshal got a
hold of it he said wrong you have to
have a generator for the building now
the only reason to have a generator for
the building would be okay for the two
hours that power goes down in downtown
Manchester for about every five or ten
years I don't exactly remember what the
letter said it's two three years ago now
okay in case someone on a six six floor
okay has something happened to them a
heart attack or what whatever the case
is okay so the fire department has to
have access to the to the elevator okay
to bring down the person on a stretcher
or whatever the case is
okay hundred and fifty thousand plus
yearly maintenance of about five
thousand dollars
there's no such thing as afford
affordable housing you can't build
affordable housing the only way you can
do it is through government entities and
with all due respect to the state of New
Hampshire and the feds and everything
else there's not enough money for
affordable housing ever in my lifetime
in your lifetime whatever the case is
it's just never going to happen with
that said you have a lot of affordable
housing out there the state of New
Hampshire has a lot of affordable
housing okay I mean the place that that
I was raised a small ranch probably a
thousand square feet on Ross Street in
Nashville Nashville New Hampshire right
across from Sandy Pond I was raised
there born there and everything else
okay it just sold for like 320. okay
that's you know now when interest rates
were at three or four percent there
really wasn't a heavy lift for a lot of
people okay there's a lot of tapes
splits everything else out there that's
affordable housing you don't need a new
house to be affordable housing I don't
think there's no need for that how many
home single-family homes are there out
there in the state a lot of them a lot
of them if you don't want to live in
Nashua or you want something that's a
little bit more affordable go out to
potentially an old uh an older house in
New Boston or Wilton or Hillsborough or
there's affordable housing out there
there always has been there always will
there will be fixer-uppers that you can
buy and get a good deal on and and build
and and rehab and and all that okay so
so so anyway I digressed a little bit so
so at 409 Elm Street we have 90
Apartments commercial first floor plenty
of parking I want to stress that plenty
of parking okay and
um so so that's my little story on the
150 000. I want to talk about landlord
tenant laws also a little bit
landlord tenant laws in the state of New
Hampshire are pretty Crystal Clear
somewhat simple for a guy like me who's
been through it over and over and over
again and I'm a Hands-On guy I go to
district court and I purchase all the
paperwork and that stuff okay okay
who does if you want to make the
landlord tenant laws more intricate
which somehow reason it it you know the
legislature and always tries to do every
single year okay who are you hurting are
you hurting a guy like me who
understands landlord tenant law
extremely well no no you might make it a
little harder a little bit more
difficult but you're not hurting me
you're hurting the person who owns that
three unit that's a neighbor of yours
that four unit that's a cousin of yours
that's six unit that invested everything
that they had okay and bought a you know
a multi that's the person and by the way
who
are they servicing those are probably
affordable units market rate affordable
units what a wonderful thing the
government's not involved okay the
cities I mean
that's who you're hurting you're not
hurting a guy like me anymore although
he still owns twos and threes and fours
and fives and sixes and that stuff okay
you're not hurting the the new guy who's
building in Downtown Manchester 250
units you're not you're not hurting the
person who's uh you know the a bigger
company uh someone's I think flatley's
building 60 80 units downtown Concord
here you're not gonna hurt him okay
because number one everybody who he
rents to there's going to be two three
thousand dollar rents okay they're gonna
have good credit okay they're gonna pay
their rent okay that they're not going
to have issues with cars and and
sickness issues where they can't pay 99
of the time
okay so so anytime anybody thinks about
making the landlord tenant issues uh
laws more strict or whatever the case is
understand you're hurting the smaller
guy or gal who's renting affordable
units okay I want to talk specifically
about what Joe talked about here and Joe
and I I didn't know Joe was going to be
here I didn't know he was going to bring
the the this up
this is an appeal that's probably going
to happen shortly okay we bought about
two and a half year years ago the Old
Camp ducat at exit one in Nashua
we we're going for approval we were
supposed to go last week it got pushed
off by five or six weeks by the way it
took us two and a half years to get
there longest story okay it got pushed
off another three or four weeks okay so
we're going for to build 83 units we're
the first one okay to be the what I'll
call and I say this kindly the guinea
pig okay to build with the new izo
zoning ordinance inclusionary zoning
ordinance in Nashua okay we have to
build nine affordable single family
housing units now remember what Joe just
said okay those nine units will not be
able to sell okay the inflation will not
impact their value so you're reducing
the worth of those people in the in
future years if they buy there by the
way I'm not sure if they can add a deck
or if they can add a porch oh looks like
I will explain why so so the zone
ordinance was passed about a year and a
half ago we met with
the planning director we met with the
mayor and saying where are the
regulations
how can you get a bank loan okay to
build something if if the banker asks
you what are you going to be able to
sell the homes for
we don't know we think we think okay two
of the homes have to be sold for about
two hundred eighty thousand a lot in
Nashua single family lots worth of has a
value about 175 200 210 okay you got to
build the entire home for about 270 to
280. then then after you have to build
seven more homes
okay for approximately 380 390 we think
the key word there is we think you know
why because they passed the ordinance a
year and a half ago we went to see the
mayor in the planning director six
months after that because we were hugely
frustrated okay we walked out of the
room the planning director says we'll
get those regulations done within a
month or two
it's a year
they're not done
so we're going to get this approved but
we it's not I don't think it's going to
get built
83 homes in Nashua at exit one
are probably not going to get built okay
because the regulations are extremely
unclear they're not passed and even the
zoning ordinance is rather unclear this
is happening right now 83 homes will not
get built most probably so let let me
let me ask you um are you is that appeal
going through the Superior Court no this
is a law firm okay that's coming to the
planning board okay to voice their
opinion concerning not uh not
suggesting to the planning board to not
accept the 83 housing units now when I
don't know where it's going to go from
for from there okay
um but I'll read you the first three
lines of one of their statements in its
current state the property is a treasure
Trove of Natural Resources especially
established mature trees in the national
land use code places great weight on
this now this is an old boy scout camp
we now own it we're paying taxes on it
okay and
a few of the neighbors use it many of
the neighbors use it for walking paths
to walk their dog to you know one
neighbor said there was a bear on it
there was a beer cave or whatever the
case is we had to hire a naturalist to
go and make sure there wasn't a bear
that lived there okay it's so it's to
say that it's
not frustrating it's it's hugely
frustrating okay
um in Nashua okay in 20 2015
282 homes closed okay in 2016 324 in
2017 322. these were all set single
family okay in night in 2023 156 have
closed so basically half and we have so
much more demand because so many people
have moved into the state we need more
homes okay no one's I'm looking for a 14
to 1600 square foot single family
there's nothing being built in Nashua
okay I have a friend who lives very
close to me or did live okay he moved to
Amherst he didn't want to move to
Amherst he bought a home that's about 20
25 years old he wanted to move into a
new home okay this nothing is virtually
nothing for sale in Nashua we want to
build 83 homes and I don't think they're
going to to get built
um
I hired it I'm sorry is that because of
the Nashua inclusion Arizona yeah and we
don't know what the regulations are and
they haven't been passed and they we we
were told they were going to be passed
within a couple months after I'm meeting
with the mayor and just not going to
happen and it hasn't happened okay
that's a year ago that's a year a year
ago okay now I'm going to talk about a
different town okay
um a few years ago I wanted to build 45
units in downtown Derry okay I own units
right next door it's an it's an empty
piece of land it's right next to the
opera house where they which they call
that their their Jewel and it is and
that's fine okay
um I needed 15 variances
okay I hired an engineer
um hint hint you may have recently
talked heard his uh his statements and
he said Ron you need 15 variances to
build what you want to build okay and
I'll give you one of the variances I
need okay per the zoning audience in
dairy uh the uh an apartment has to be
800 square feet okay I have built 60 of
my 80 apartments in downtown Manchester
are under 800 square feet
okay okay I got that through
okay so what did I do 15 variances this
guy told me run it would be better to
hit your head against the wall and I saw
so I just stopped okay so I still own
the piece of land okay I I have other
buildings on it it's paying for the
taxes okay I can't do everything okay so
I chose to go in a different direction
um it's again that's my fault I should
be talking to the Town Council I should
uh potentially try to vote in in all
these towns it's illegal I'm just
kidding that about that okay but you
know it's and I think your hands are
tight
your hands are tied I shouldn't be
talking to you I should be talking in
front of the board of Miranda Alderman
in Nashua I bet you anything they don't
know what's happening with their zoning
ordinance right now and the the Ico that
that much okay I should be in in front
of the Town Council in Derry
okay I should be
doing a lot of what I'll call political
stuff
I don't have time
I got to work this morning at seven
okay there's only so many things that I
can do and I'm trying to manage and rent
and run 1800 Apartments that's a
challenge okay
um
I think I'm missing one subject but that
that's okay uh
well thank you Mr Dupont are there any
questions representative McConkey
uh thank you sir uh for being here and I
appreciate your point of view I was just
adding up I think the most properties
I've ever had under my management was
about 195 and that took all of my day so
I commend you at 1800.
um you had mentioned
um
the town of Derry one of their
requirements was 800 square feet uh
you're a man that has been doing this
many times and I'm sure you've done
infill apartments and new construction
what do you see the market what how many
square feet are you typically proposing
to build
um well let's pick a perfect example
something that I just built okay there
were a 90 90 Apartments okay I have uh
10 apartments with some revolutionary
Cloud beds longest story there okay the
bed just goes up in the air okay
um those are expensive okay those are
364 square feet okay I have some largest
Studios that are about 400 70 square
feet like so so the the cloud bed Studio
I think I have 10 of them the the other
Studios I think I have uh another ten
don't quote me okay and then after I
have a lot of one beds 40 one beds that
are about
um
either 680 or 720 square feet and I have
22 beds that are
950 60 square square feet okay
um and the the affordable the studios
Okay
um that's I from my perspective a
a a portion of the affordable housing
out there now that they're not
you know depending on your Viewpoint
those are going for fifteen hundred
dollars a month okay but it includes
Wi-Fi
um it includes a lot of things okay uh
I'm sorry go ahead and if I could follow
up so the way where you're speaking of
of the the mix of 360 to 950 was that it
is that at your 409 Elm Street property
yes yes thank you sir yep
any other questions representative
um can we go back to the State Fire
Marshal
um issue that you had
um
were they trying to
enforce some
some uh regulations that they have or a
state law
um do you know
um it's certainly it they consider it a
health and safety issue obviously okay
um okay either statutes written on it to
be honest with you I'm not absolutely
sure okay
okay represent McConkey um thank you and
thank the representative for jogging my
memory here so representative that's not
here a member of the commission had a
piece of legislation that came through
committee and approved uh where the town
had gone through for private land owner
on a private piece of property the town
standard was I think eight feet for a
private driveway to one residence went
through the whole process built built it
everything the planning board said he
could do should do just have the fire
Marsh or fire chief come in and say you
know that driveway's got to be 12 feet
wide times 300 you know foot in length
and we're not going to give your
occupancy permit it got worked out to a
certain point but we passed legislation
that said if if
um if a person goes through a town
planning process and receives all of
their approvals and the fire marshal or
the fire chief has recommendations above
and beyond that the planning board will
consider those thoughts
and we got we got the fire marshal to
buy into that so I'm I'm wondering if
maybe we expand that language so okay so
I I I I really am glad to hear your
testimony and talking about having to
throw a a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar generator for the inavailability
of something that might happen once or
once or twice a year but if not once or
twice a year it's probably you know I
mean it's a lot less than that but would
you would you agree as a developer if if
I I I'm a developer I I want to know the
rules I only work in towns that have
zoning because I want to know the rules
I want to know what my costs are if we
could somehow get language in there to
that effect would you think that would
be beneficial to you as a rather large
developer yes okay and understand that
the authority in the state of New
Hampshire that's the most powerful is
the fire department
understand that okay
very important statement that I just
made okay
all right well at any more questions for
Mr DuPont
go ahead representative
um
what do you think think about uh there's
been some talk about
um
additional requirements
um that it kind of goes back to your
Innovative
um
zoning issue or not inclusionary zoning
issue
um that
that um
the board or the zoning board or the
planning board putting on regulations or
requirements on top of the actual stated
requirements
in the
um in the zoning or in the regulations
after the
um the you know you you read them you
you design a plan that meets them and
then you go and they're like oh we want
to do this but that's not in the
regulations
um and so you have to go back and do
more work has that ever happened to you
what do you think about requiring that
they oh that they cannot put in
additional requirements on that they
have not previously you know published
and had public hearings on et cetera et
cetera I mean there is language that was
just put in that the fees have to be
published well fees that's one thing
there's other requirements right to your
point exactly okay so I'm not sure I get
the the the years correct I think okay
um I I think I may have my notes but we
we bought the Doucette property exit 127
Acres okay
um in something like May of two years
ago
so we signed the purchase and sale
five months before
okay we had no idea izo regulations were
even contemplated by the city of Nashua
we purchased it our attorney Andy
Pearlman who's probably the most
well-known land planning attorney in
Nashua didn't know about it either
because he handled the the transaction
somehow we found out okay so now all of
a sudden we got to build okay nine
affordable units at at the beginning we
didn't know what price it hadn't even
passed the zoning board longer story
they slowed it down in my humble opinion
that's only my opinion okay so that we
just couldn't get it through
um and so then after they passed the
ordinance and and now we're just getting
there with no regulations so so I so I
think to your statement we bought it
with no idea okay even when we owned it
for quite a while we had no idea and
then after they passed the Ico and that
puts huge pressure on land okay at the
end of the day I think this land still
has the value that we paid for it but in
potentially a real world or not in a
hyper housing World okay whatever we
paid it would be worth less because
you can't put in regulations that impact
your use without impacting value for the
most part now it could be you put could
put regulations I guess in or take them
away that that a positive okay in this
case they're negative remember
if we if we could just build out that
land it would be it would be built right
now it would be being built so okay so
with 60 to 80 homes
well thank you Mr Dupont it's been
helpful
um you've given us a lot to think about
so thank you very much thank you
thank you all right so with that we're
going to take a lunch break we'll be
back at one o'clock for a presentation
thank you
okay it is 105 104. Welcome Back special
committee on housing
um the next presenter I want to have up
is James veyo who is uh former grad
school colleague of mine I think we took
the art of negotiation together so I
think we are using that in real life
today so I appreciate you coming and
presenting on um adus and on behalf of
New Hampshire housings thank you
and just hit the red the button for us
so it turns red I see okay thank you uh
that's uh you can hear me okay yes great
yeah no uh a pleasure and a real
opportunity uh a a joy to come up here
and do this so thank you chairman for
extending the invitation and uh I hope
you guys get a lot out of this
presentation
so today I want to talk to you about
policy and program models for creating
accessory dwelling units in New
Hampshire
uh
this project uh included a team of
myself as lead researcher and writer and
the speaker for you today uh also Sylvia
Alec uh from Southern New Hampshire
Planning Commission and Benjamin Frost
from New Hampshire housing
just a quick note that uh this project
wouldn't have been possible without New
Hampshire housing that provided the
funding to conduct This research
uh and just a quick note on the mission
for New Hampshire housing they have a
mission to promote finance and support
affordable housing for the people of New
Hampshire and since 1981 they've built
more than
um they've helped more than 45 000
families purchase a home and they've
built more than 15 000 multi-family
units in the state so it's it's uh
nothing to sneeze at
why are we talking about adus today well
uh as a solution to housing it's
necessary there's a a lot changing about
the economy uh an affordability of
housing is as uh a low if not an
all-time low right now
um the inability of our state to build
sufficient housing presents a real risk
to the overall economy and uh we've seen
that uh Community Health assessments
have identified housing as a primary or
key need in order to achieve positive
Health outcomes for uh the people of New
Hampshire
as a solution adus offer a lower cost
alternative to traditional forms of
housing that we've seen built in the
state over the last couple decades
I had a couple slides in here about
declining Supply you guys have already
seen a lot of that I think by now so I
cut them out in the the skinny here is
that with such a low vacancy rate in the
state it blocks the ability of people to
choose housing and it uh is keeping
people from entering into Home Ownership
which is
a pretty key goal for social stability
I won't go through all this but uh there
are a lot of ways that adus create
opportunities across Society
in this table I have here just looks at
a cross-section of different uh elements
of society such as economic social
environmental uh
um focus or disciplines and then the
users of adus or the beneficiaries of
adus such as homeowners renters families
seniors in the general public and uh
really there's there's a a multitude of
ways the adus can have a positive impact
on society that's kind of the takeaway
from the slide so if you're interested
in getting into any of the details of
what I flash in the screen here today I
will present I will share these slides
with you and and you can dive into them
in more detail
and almost all this content shows up in
the the report that's available on New
Hampshire housing's website
before we dive into research I just want
to talk about I got three slides here to
talk about what Nadu is in New Hampshire
and so RSA 674 71 defines adus and of uh
in
674.72 is uh language around uh kind of
framing what's allowable for a to use
and so I've highlighted a couple of
things here I just want to hit upon
which are important uh important to the
production of adus in the state
and the first one is the definition
defines native as attached
or within a single family dwelling and
there is additional language uh in RSA
73 which uh conflicts with this it says
a town may allow detached and so this is
something I want to focus on there's a
little bit of conflict within the
state's language and uh it leaves the
door open to restricting to attached
only
uh some other things here on the right
hand side uh
it says here that uh adus can be loud as
a matter of right uh like a Buy Right
Use or at through a conditional use
permit or a special exception of the
zoning
um and that opens the door to requiring
hearing hearings in order to get your
Adu permitted
so something to keep note of
this Section 3 has something about
requiring an interior door between the
principal unit and the and the accessory
unit this really only applies to
attached data use but the language again
for somebody who doesn't know the rules
that well might find this confusing
section uh six here
a municipality may require owner
occupancy and we've seen in uh the state
of New Hampshire that you know somewhere
between around a half of the
municipalities to two-thirds uh require
owner occupancy
and then we already covered this 73 the
last one here about allowing uh
municipalities to choose whether or not
to allow detached adus
so that's New Hampshire's rules in a
nutshell abbreviated
um what did we see in our national
research well uh there's
three uh regulations that uh put it
pretty put have a pretty significant
cooling effect on the production of adus
and those three regulations are owner
occupancy requirements
off-street parking requirements and
conditional use permit hearings so those
three things alone uh
put a significant dent in the number of
people who would have the capacity to go
pull a permit for an Adu
just based on knowledge and skill
on the right hand side we have a few
more and I sorry I kind of butchered the
numbers here uh but there's limiting
regulations around the dimensional size
of an Adu that also limit how and where
adus can get built Brothers other than
to note them
uh things like lot setbacks having large
lot setbacks limits uh where an Adu is
possible especially in Village centers
or uh the cities of New Hampshire
uh size limits that are proportional to
Primary Home tend to have uh be a little
bit regressive uh towards people who
have small homes because then they can
only have an even smaller Adu so that
creates some challenges uh minimum lot
sizes which luckily in New Hampshire we
don't have that issue
um
the the prevailing zoning is required to
control the lot size for adus in New
Hampshire so that's it's a non-issue
then type restriction so we just saw
this in the previous slide that New
Hampshire allows municipalities to
restrict detached at you that uh
restricting detached datus has a pretty
significant cooling effect on the
production of adus
and then finally development fees uh
it's there's there's documented proof
that uh when these fees are waived
either permanently or for a period of
time to jump start the production
um that it has a a measurable impact on
the number of permits that are requested
and all this is pretty thick so we'll
get through this and then you won't have
to look at this anymore uh we'll get
into some lighter content but uh these
are a couple recommendations I would
have for the state in terms of
increasing Adu production just through
amendments to RSA 674. uh the first one
is to change the definition to include
detached adus the second is to make all
adus and as of right use so eliminate
that conditional use permit hearing I I
you know I I don't think that that's
something that would go over easy uh you
know in terms of the effect on local
land control but if you wanted to have
an impact where adus were being built at
higher rates it has proven that what do
you mean by I'm sorry what do you mean
by conditional use permits that's a good
question yes so uh the the
yes so there's you could either have a
hearing through your zoning or planning
board which uh that hearing would
involve you proving that there's a need
for you to have this and you would need
to notify your Butters go to the hearing
um the the the the board that's
overseeing this use permit would then
have
the opportunity to provide feedback
about your project and attach certain
stipulations to its approval or they
could outright deny your request so uh
if you think about this from the terms
of a homeowner they might need to spend
a several thousand dollars you know get
a site survey hire an engineering
professionals a civil professional and
architect to present plans and they
might do all that and still get to a no
answer and so they might spend several
thousand dollars that they could not
then not recoup so that that presents a
real risk to the household
um you know if the household's a little
better off maybe they can afford to take
that risk but
um we we know that
uh something like two-thirds of
households don't have you know more than
a week or two of uh salary Savings in
their bank accounts so they they just
literally don't even have the money to
get through the hearing process
as of right is uh uh usually an
application process so you would fill
out an application all the rules would
be laid out in front of you by the staff
the planning staff would put together a
checklist you would fill out the
checklist you provide all the
documentation requested and then the
staff would review it and either approve
it or deny it and in some rare instances
they may ask for it to go for a hearing
uh two other recommendations here uh it
one is to override local off street
parking requirements one of the things
we heard from the zoning Atlas was that
some towns had Fairly High requirements
three four parking spaces for an Adu
which seems like kind of a thinly veiled
way to block Adu production
and so it seems that local local land
use boards are sort of abusing their
their powers to to restrict this kind of
housing type
uh and then fourth is the owner
occupancy requirement this is a little
bit of a double-edged sword people get
upset at the idea of eliminating owner
occupancy requirement uh and the reason
is it it makes the home more vulnerable
to becoming an investment product for
someone someone buys it rents out both
the main house and the Adu and then now
that's out of the pool of people who can
compete to own and own a home right
that's a real risk the other end of that
is we know that when you know large
Capital Pools get a hold of a successful
model for profit they would churn these
things out in in big numbers and so you
have to kind of choose your path which
way you want to go so when people ask me
my recommendation owner occupancy
requirement
I I really don't I don't have a
recommendation that is
it it depends on what you want to
achieve if you really want to achieve
home ownership then require the owner
occupancy if you want to build a whole
lot of units in a short amount of time
then remove the owner occupancy unit
s all right so I apologize that was kind
of thick and a little a little much but
I just wanted to hit on that because we
don't really talk about it for the rest
of it and the reason I brought up all
this local regulatory stuff is as you'll
see later in this presentation almost
every one of the case studies uh started
with some kind of liberalization of
local regulations and then momentum
built from there and so you'll see the
theme of this unfold as we go but
in short uh the research goals are are
as follows to explore policies and
programs implemented in other states
seeking to encourage and support the
creation of adus
and the tools and techniques so uh we
present how in this report how New
Hampshire can use these identified
um strategies of other locations in
order to develop their own regulations
and programs to stimulate the creation
of adus
and the scope work kind of breaks down
like this case study research we'll talk
about those analysis of policy
identified tools and techniques
scenarios for Adu production and then
not in this presentation but in the
report that's on New Hampshire housing's
web page
all of this has you know there's
probably over a hundred links to Source
materials and reference materials
throughout it so if somebody was
inspired by anything they saw in this
report they would very quickly be able
to get to the core information of how
the policy is run and how the program is
operated and replicate it if they wanted
to do that
so let's talk about case studies
there's three areas of focus that we set
out with and when we started this
research it was affordability programs
pre-approved plan programs and design
initiatives so let's talk about the
first one I'll give an example of one of
these for each of these Focus areas
so we'll start with affordability
on a high level I'll just mention the
three case studies that exist for the
affordability uh component of This
research the three are Barnstable Mass
which is Cape Cod or a good chunk of
Cape Cod uh Boston Massachusetts both of
those have loan programs and then the
third is California which has a grant
program and so uh the first two are
really focused on local programs and
initiatives in California is is a state
initiative so we'll look at the state
one since you guys that's kind of your
scope here we're talking about State
stuff
so California
's uh our biggest state in the nation
it's 44 million people it's enormous
California has a program that was part
of a much larger legislative action on
adus and housing which again liberalized
rules around adus and invested a
significant amount of money into
facilitating production across a whole
range of uh elements of housing it's not
that different than the invest NH
initiative that the state of New
Hampshire uh recently undertook
within this larger legislative action uh
they had this 100 million dollars set
aside for adus and it sounds like an
enormous number and it is because it's
an enormous state but uh as we'll see
later if you uh sort of uh scale that to
the population of New Hampshire it would
be not more than a four million dollar
program so so totally feasible
achievable size scale program for the
State of New Hampshire
so what do they do here they have a
grant and to be eligible for it you have
to be a working class household so what
how do you define that that's uh less
than 120 percent of the area of median
income
and the grant uh is designed to serve
these households to help them get over
the hurdle of uh permitting and approval
and so
um the way they do this is that
California Housing Finance Authority uh
is administering the Grant and they work
directly with lending institutions to be
the grant escrow managers so the state
passes this bill says Housing Finance
Authority go figure out how to get this
money out in the community the Housing
Finance Authority goes to the local
banks and says we would like you to sign
up to serve as the escrow manager for
these funds and work with households to
get them to a place where they can build
their Adu and in return that homeowner
is probably going to take a loan with
you to build to do the construction part
of their project which is really pretty
clever it plays the incentives of the
lender it places the incentives of the
homeowner and uh links them together
it's pretty smart
uh the state of California managed to
spend this hundred million dollars in
just a few short months which is pretty
incredible it shows the Merit of how
efficiently the program was run and uh
it provided a booster shot to the Adu
industry in the State uh you know within
the last two years the Adu industry has
seen uh
literally dozens of manufactured uh uh
Adu uh so prefabricated accessory
dwelling unit manufacturers popping up
all over the state and we're not talking
like small outfits build a dozen here
but it doesn't there we're talking uh
factories 200 300 000 square feet you
know anticipating building hundreds of
adus a year so a pretty substantial
investment of capital by the Private
Industry as a response to this 100
million dollars pushing demand into a a
place where it was feasible for Capital
to invest in it
so uh so we we talked about kind of the
the framework of the the program and how
how it works I haven't told you what the
use of the funds were and that's
pre-development cost and so all eligible
costs would be the design of the Adu the
permitting of the Adu so to get all your
approvals in place the site work so any
kind of groundwork that we you know need
to put in a new sewer line or something
between the house and the Adu you can do
that and then finally if you have money
left over after all that you can buy
down interest rate points on your loan
with the bank it's another reason to
work with the bank this is uh Mutual
sort of relationship
this program is very well designed to
serve households that don't have cash on
hand but likely have a pretty high level
of equity in their home and that's a key
group to work with you know they want to
build an Adu but they don't have the ten
thousand dollars to get permitting
approval to get a loan well we'll help
you get through that portion and get
your loan and boom they're on their way
they've they've got a new Revenue Source
or they're housing a family member at a
much lower cost than they would have
otherwise
some some side notes about this housing
and Finance Authority worked with the
state's planning office to document and
and track data on this so it's kind of
hard to read at the scale but all those
little thoughts are constructed and
permitted adus within the state and uh
because they they have all this
excellent source data there's a lot of
really good research going on about the
effects of Adu production on the economy
of California so something to keep in
mind
just to put things back into perspective
here
they've built 22 600 something adus and
a two-year span
but that's only 0.3 percent of all
single family housing stock in the state
of California so it's it's literally a
drop in the bucket like if you got to
think about this stuff in terms of scale
so uh you know it it's it all seems very
massive until you think about it in in
relation to the 44 million people that
live there
uh I already talked about this a little
bit but this yellow box is the high home
equity low-income household or maybe Low
Cash reserves uh a key demographic to
serve because once they get over that
hurdle of getting permanent approvals in
a construction loan they're good to go
they're in a really good place and
you're serving a group that likely has a
higher housing need than the rest of the
population
all right so that's affordability I give
you one example out of three because
we're a little short on time but uh I'd
like to now talk about pre-approved
plans and so you might be asking what is
a pre-approved plan and uh the
pre-approved plan is basically an
architectural plan of the Adu that is
stamped and ready to be used so all the
review process is taking place for that
unit
except for where it touches the ground
right and this has a lot of value in
terms of cutting down the amount of
Labor that a planning department has to
do to review a unit if they have the
same Adu come through and they've
already stamped it and they're reusing
those plans they don't have to check any
of the engineering or roof loads live
loads they don't have to check Ada you
know compatibility they don't have to
review any of the engineering elements
they can go straight to determining if
the unit meets the site requirements or
the zoning dimensional requirements and
so that can cut a significant amount of
time off this if you start seeing 10 20
38 views a month which
you know uh in my mind is probably a
place we want to get to we probably want
to get to a place where municipalities
are approving dozens of these you know
if not over a hundred a year if we can
get to that place we can put a
meaningful dent in housing demand
so for this one there is no state level
example but Seattle is the best example
of the three here and so we're going to
take a look at Seattle
so Seattle Washington is an interesting
case study because uh it was split about
50 50 down the middle about whether the
population wanted a to use or didn't
want adus really half the population was
I don't want those in my backyard and I
want them in this neighborhood they're
going to cause traffic congestion
they're going to take parking you know
all the typical things we hear about
growth you know that people are
concerned about some legitimate and some
maybe not but
um but all of that was true in Seattle
and so because of that the planning
department had to be very diligent about
every
step they took to facilitate policy so
it's not upset
anybody right like they really want to
show the Merit of the process they
followed in order to to not have people
pick apart their their their efforts
and so the way they did this uh once you
know the city kind of waffled back and
forth and then Washington State stepped
in in the state passed a law it said
adus of the law of the land now so this
is true in Seattle uh Washington in
Oregon California
and a couple other states you know they
basically say 80 user a Buy Right Use
now so
um so once that happened they got uh
Seattle started this process of putting
together information for the public to
use in
um
in developing or building their own edu
and so they have a very thoughtful and
useful step-by-step guide for Adu
production like what it what it what
process do I need to follow in order to
do it and uh this represents a really
well done technical assistance from the
planning staff to the General Public
within that
um they have their pre-approved plan
program and they have a library of over
160 Adu plans but not all of them are
pre-approved the the 160 plans came out
of a solicitation process that was sent
out to design professionals they said
we would like to pre-approve a specific
number of adus and we would like you to
submit your plans and we will determine
uh whether those plans uh are sort of
the highest and best purpose for the
Public's desires and so they set out
these criteria and uh the criteria was
developed through a public survey so it
wasn't just the planning staff
determining what was important in an Adu
is let's go out and ask homeowners what
they want in Adu renters what they want
in Adu and then they develop the
criteria for the design professionals or
respond to that they then said you can
respond on this submission but you have
to pick a category you know is this Adu
going to be green green building is it
going to be affordable is it going to be
flexible future use you have to
determine which one of these you're
you're submitting your plan under
um
and then they had a panel to review all
the plans that came in and they selected
the 12 best plans and they put those in
for the pre-approval process so it's
very useful way to limit the scope of
work that the staff had to do to review
and get these plans ready for the public
consumption but also everything's
transparent the whole process they use
the survey results from the public the
decision making and scoring process for
the plans that were awarded the fact
that all the plans that were submitted
can be downloaded and the plans reviewed
and looked at by the public
in all of this really serves to
instigate discussion amongst the public
about what is important in housing
around adus
part of how this program functions now
that this library of 12 units is in
place is that the designer of the unit
gets to charge a fee if a homeowner
chooses to build using those plans and
so uh there's a license fee on the web
for for using the the plan available on
the web page and the license fee is
important because it establish an
engagement between the homeowner and the
design professional and
for for every homeowner that thinks they
want to use a pre-approved plan then
comes along some idea about how they
want to change it they want to move a
door here they want to change a wall
here they want to push something out
three feet over there well when that
happens it's no longer a proof plan they
need a design professional to bring that
plan into into compliance right so uh so
it builds a relationship where the
design professional can modify those
plans and then go through the
traditional approval process if desired
or if the homeowner just uses the plans
as designed they might want a a
construction representative a
homeowner's rep an owner's rep during
construction and so they would hire that
architect who designed those plans
probably knows them well it's probably
overseen the construction of multiple
iterations of that plan to then oversee
construction on behalf of the homeowner
and protect them from risk involved with
construction
uh on the designer side they get to
retain ownership of this plan and so uh
what we found in the research is and you
know bear with me this is very Pacific
Northwest so this doesn't look like New
England architecture but um what happens
is because the owner uh the architect or
the design professional retains
ownership of these plans they're really
incentivized to put forward the most
effective product to lure homeowners to
use their plan and it again it plays two
incentives and so what we're looking at
here is three of the 12 plans that are
pre-approved in Seattle uh one's a small
cottage one's a two bed two bath so
pretty substantial size uh larger than
than most towns allow in New Hampshire
at a thousand square feet and then
something kind of in between
um again all these plans are available
on the website but I thought it would be
valuable to show you this image because
then you get a sense of the level of
quality that went into these what we saw
from Chico and Eugene is that when you
don't use a solicitation process and you
hire a design professional or you have
in-house staff do it the quality of the
pre-approved plan is not nearly as uh as
nice as this and you don't get as good a
product and it doesn't instigate as much
participation from the public in
building adus
some other quick notes about Seattle
they have a really nice online map you
can use to look through and see if you
meet all the requirements and where you
might have uh
uh you might get flagged for additional
review as a really effective tool
uh I don't show all of it here but I
highly recommend checking this out you
go to their ad Universe web page and you
can scroll around this map if you want
to check it out it is it is a real it's
real fun to use you just pick any random
house and say oh would it would nadieu
work here and why and why not
they also have all the rules around you
to use on this webpage easy to reference
you don't have to go digging through the
you know some deep into some web portal
to find the regulations on adus you can
do it right from the single web page
what else uh do they do here they track
data just like we saw from California's
uh planning department they track all
the permitting in all the applications
and who's living in these things what
kind of households and serving how it's
affecting the housing market in Seattle
how it's impacting other resources that
go into housing it's really useful they
then on an annual basis put this
together in a report that they give to
government officials that are
responsible for policy making to guide
their guide their decision around future
policy or amendments
and uh that in a nutshell Seattle
one last key you know I don't know if
you guys have any questions about your
scene here but uh we'll give one last
case study and then we can talk about
identified tools and techniques
all right I'll go through this real
quick because it's it's probably less
relevant to
what you're doing at the state level
so in Los Angeles there's a small
neighborhood in the Northeast and
there's this group called Lamas and
there are community
a community design organization so what
what what's a community design
organization they uh they are basically
a non-profit that lends help to
community residents in solving issues
around design could be with their
property uh could be with the Civic
realm so Street design or you know could
be with how to uh manage storefronts in
a little Village Center or something
like that and so they they can do all
these things as a design center at as a
non-profit
Lamas worked with elected officials to
create an Adu pilot project to
demonstrate the ways to meet the
community needs through adus as an
affordable housing option
and they selected a couple of a
household to participate in this pilot
project and designed a two-bedroom Adu
with an attached garage to serve the
needs of that selected homeowner so here
on the right we have kind of a fun
little image shows you know uh sort of
conceptual
visualization of what this thing would
look like and on the next slide well we
can uh we talked they just the hitting
the bullets here the three things they
really wanted to demonstrate was
well-designed home in a low cost
the ability to finance adus
and how government can play a role in
making it easier to build them so all
three of these things were
this is this Project's pretty old now so
this is from years ago but it is a
useful uh example of how non-profits can
play a role in facilitating government
uh action on easing housing needs
and so uh so in this next slide there's
a floor plans on the left is this first
floor you can see the car in the garage
and there's kind of a shared kitchen
living room and an open space and a
stairwell in between those two spaces
in the Upper Floor you have two bedrooms
and a small bathroom and laundry area
what they built pretty much is Verbatim
what they had in the concept and uh the
design is quality and I think I think
you know this is very much Los Angeles
architecture you know uh like Southern
uh Craftsman style architecture
reimagined but but it's it's playful and
fun and the architecture is inspiring
and the building is beautiful and uh I
wanted to include this case study
because I I firmly believe that a lot of
the rejection we get in in New Hampshire
and Society of uh growth is the ugliness
of growth and so I think if we can solve
some of that right if we cannot build
ugly buildings uh people would be a lot
less hesitant to support growth so
uh they were very successful with this
pilot it inspired elected officials to
want to work with them and inspired the
non-profit to want to think bigger about
how they could scale this up and they
came up with this program called the
backyard homes project where they
developed a series of different plans
that the public you know the residents
of Northeast La could use uh as a basis
point for designing an Adu and then they
worked to partner the homeowner with a
with a low-income tenant and then
facilitate the use of Hud funding to
build the Adu so it's a very creative
program and uh it's linked in here and
you'll find it in the report but they
they put together all these resources
including a project road map and a
detailed program booklet and an
information sheet to show homeowners how
to go through this process and if the
homeowner want to do it this uh non this
community Design Group would would walk
them through the process
so uh we don't get in we don't have to
get into all this but
um
Lamaze the the mission of Lamaze was
very much neighborhood Focus
and this program was so successful it
outgrew the neighborhood into the
regional level and so as a result of
that
um this program spun off into something
called office of office and so it's it's
a little less pertinent to what we're
talking about but uh it's worth noting
that
you know these things are organic and if
with success they morph and meet the
needs so
all right so we've got tools and
techniques we identified five the first
three were where we started we started
this initial research looking at
affordability calling Financial
incentives here uh pre-approved Adu
plans and then design initiatives so
things like design competitions
Community technical assistance
and then what we found is that in most
of these case studies the there was this
momentum building that went along with
these things and that initiated with
liberalizing of ADA regulations and or
the process of approval
as an initial step and then staff and
other groups stepped in to provide
technical assistance Outreach and
education of the public and those things
built momentum to do the things we saw
on the first three panels This
affordability pre-approved plans and
design initiatives
so we reorganized this based on uh level
of effort we think needs to go into it
in order to implement and so all the way
on the left we've reorganized technical
assistance as the first thing it's an
easy lift staff can usually do technical
assistance to help homeowners build an
Adu for very little or no cost might
cost some of their time but they can do
these things so that looks like
permitting and approval Assistance or
one-on-one assistance creating an Adu
checklist for homeowners to use or
holding informal homeowner workshops
where they can ask questions in a
hypothetical basis without having to put
together a formalized review
then things kind of build from there you
can do Outreach and education you could
hire media firms to help you put
together informational videos then if uh
if you want to go further you can look
at design initiatives you can hold an
Adu design competition you could build a
pilot project things start to get more
expensive require more time and energy
you can put together a pre-approved Adu
plans library
and my recommendation was you use a
solicitation process to do that don't
hire a design professional through a
contract so that you get the best
quality product
and then finally we can look at
providing affordability incentives
things like loans and grants to support
design permitting and construction
with all these tools identified we ran
them across the case studies and
categorized them so it's a little hard
to read at the scale so I apologize but
I'll send you a slide set and you can
look at more detail this also was given
in the executive summary and is an easy
to use reference guide for looking at
particular types of approaches to
incentivizing or supporting the
production of adus
so you can almost think of it as a
different type of table of contents and
so across the top where you have nearly
every one of them has an X that's uh
reductions in zoning and then as we
talked about easy lifts technical
assistance and then up to financial
incentives you know requiring the most
resources and buy-in the red X's are the
initial
uh Focus area of research for that
particular case study so Barnstable Mass
we're looking at affordability for
constructing adus
California we were looking at
affordability around permitting and
approval of adus and so on kind of
carries across the table
so we've covered the tools and
techniques
we've talked about the case studies and
what I'd like to do is run through three
scenarios and one bonus scenario and
that's all I got I used my whole 45
minutes so I apologize I'll go through
this real quick
couple scenarios for how New Hampshire
can translate this Research into
models of production so this first one
and I cut out there's a couple other
ones we did here that were at the
municipal scale and even bother showing
those because you guys are really
focused on state level stuff all right
so so this first one is a regional level
Adu Library so a lot of small towns
don't have the resources to put together
pre-approved plans right but when you
collect those all together under a
regional Planning Commission now you can
do something you can get a dozen towns
to all have the same pre-approved plan
on their books and the Planning
Commission can manage that Library
so uh to do this the the regional
Planning Commission would work with the
town to collaborate on what criteria
they want to set first for developing
plans the the Planning Commission would
do the solicitation process the survey
of residence and
um the Planning Commission would work
with the local officials to determine
what content needs to be in those plans
in order for them to be pre-approved
and then finally the Planning Commission
would maintain the library over time it
might need periodic updating let's say
the state changes their zoning code now
as plans need to be rechecked against
new zoning code they might need some
minor modifications
so that's scenario a
scenario B zero interest deferred loans
we didn't talk about this in the
affordability component but Barnstable
and Boston both have zero interest
deferred loan programs and they're both
a little different ones targeted at rent
affordability for renters and ones are
targeted at affordability for the
homeowner and so
the state of New Hampshire can replicate
either of those programs it can put
together uh requirements for
um
based on income limitations
to in order to support affordable
housing unit production as adus
the the one thing about this is that uh
it initially requires a lot of
capitalization just like a small
business loan fund or any kind of uh
Enterprise Loan Fund that you might see
at the municipal level it requires a big
chunk of money up front to get it going
and then it can kind of feed off of
itself
scenario C do what California did
develop a pre-approved pre-development
Grant give homeowners forty thousand
dollars if they income qualify if you
size that at four million dollars in New
Hampshire you'd be able to build 180 to
use and they would come real quick you
know do you build 180 Us in less than a
year it's basically how that would go
um it's just a way to jump start and
normalize Adu production help businesses
get off their feet help the industry
figure out how to finance them get
things moving once they're moving
people send to accept it and it should
build momentum on itself
this is a bonus uh here this one last
one what's possible there's this really
cool program out of Portland Oregon uh
Hacienda CDC which is Community
Development Corporation led a pilot
projected to demonstrate how to build at
scale modular housing units uh not
specifically as adus but I think they
would make great adus uh and the state
provided 5 million in funding to support
this initial pilot production and that
translated into a 44 million dollar
Grant from Eda to grow an emerging
market around Timber Products and what's
so unique about this is they build this
with uh like a cross laminated Timber or
a wood Mass wall so the wall is solid
wood and the whole way across its panel
like a giant thick piece of plywood and
you'd think well that doesn't seem very
efficient but the thing is uh for
whatever reason in Oregon they have a
lot of byproduct trees Timber that is
not suitable as Lumber stock two by
fours you know four by Eights things
like that and so the product doesn't
have a high use value proposal outside
of Home Depot so what do they do they
turn it into this panel and they're
building local housing products out of
it so it's really really interesting
um innovation
and so New Hampshire could do something
like this they could build six prototype
units with some Innovative Building
Technology maybe work with UNH to
determine what that is uh provide these
projects uh through design construction
delivery and field monitoring and then
um
and then perhaps maybe that would scale
into a larger production year over year
drop the cost of these things and then
become Market viable on their own so I
apologize I went like really long really
fast but that is that's all the content
I have for you
well thank you that's been that's been
helpful so we hear about adus I think
the most helpful part was the beginning
where you told us recommended changes
and I think
um it's given me a lot to think about I
don't know about the rest of us
um are there any questions for Mr Bale
representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question it is getting back to the
beginning of it with recommended changes
uh you were talking about a proposal to
make them buy right so people wouldn't
necessarily need to get surveys because
they don't have a lot of money
again you explained later where they're
going to get the money to build it if
they don't even have the money for a
survey would you recommend building
anything on home
or a detached Adu if we went down that
road
in a meets and Bounds State like New
Hampshire with Antiquated borders
without a survey
well buy right doesn't necessarily mean
that you would be able to build without
a survey although a survey does elevate
the cost you know the towns could set
that through their zoning what the
requirements are for submitting an
application and a survey could be one of
the things they require as part of that
application to build an EDU
my recommendation would be you know I
wouldn't require more than a plot plan
and that the owner certified that the
plot plan is accurate uh and this is in
the 80s is how a lot of single-family
homes were built including my own
um you know maybe we've moved past as a
society and we can't go back there but
um
I know when I wanted to build Adu on my
property I had to pay two thousand
dollars to get a survey done not the end
of the world but
um you know it was it's a cost
go ahead follow up and again I'm just
being realistic about this surveys are
critical for an example you referenced
your home cost me six thousand dollars
to find out that my plot plan didn't
match the survey so thank you
uh representative
yes
you do not
okay I have a question regarding
um off-street parking regulations do you
know
um
how many Municipal not how many but like
how often that's used as a as a
hindrance to building adus in New
Hampshire and I mean my what I'm
thinking something realistic is saying
like you can require up to one parking
spot per bedroom or something I'm trying
to think of like something that's
realistic that can accommodate but also
be like all right you can't set like
four parking spots per one bedroom Adu
doesn't make sense to me
yeah one per driver yeah they may not be
driving any longer yeah yeah I I think
the idea of you know requiring one per
bedroom is uh within totally within the
realm of reason
uh you know I I live in the city of
Manchester
we we allow overnight on street parking
on street and most of our streets have
plenty of capacity to uh manage that
kind of cars on the street especially in
single-family neighborhoods there's
plenty of room for cars on the road
um
the the reason why I bring it up for
Manchester up is
um a lot of the housing that exists has
a long skinny driveway to a carriage
house in the back right so you have this
you have a lot maybe it's 50 feet wide
the house is taking up 30 feet you get a
driveway 12 feet you're pretty much
there right if you then go say you can
only build an Adu if you add another
parking space it pretty much knocks all
of that housing type out of contention
for building an Adu
um and like that's you know we we think
like okay the car is an apple absolute
requisite because we don't want to
create undue burden on the community but
in many scenarios that homeowner's not
going to have
someone who drives in it might be
grandma might be I don't know somebody
that's walking to work if they're in an
inner Village and so I you know I think
what you're proposing as far as a state
Max on uh requirements for parking makes
sense and then it still leaves the
flexibility for a place like Manchester
to determine when and where and how to
require less parking if they want to do
that for example maybe it's on a high
frequency bus route for MTA and you can
get into the city now maybe if you look
at La that's what they did they say if
you're on a Transit line you don't have
a parking requirement so there's lots of
creative ways to do that okay
representative
thank you
um you talked a little bit about these
different
um
things that you were studying how you
some of them were uh you said old
um and
um so like the California one
um
what what year was that and then is
there what what other benefits I guess
um have they seen so they put you know
they they put in the
the they spent the 100 million dollars
and you're talking about like hey maybe
there's an industry that makes it market
rate or whatever has there been enough
time to see if that um those twenty
thousand adus are repeated did that drop
back down to five thousand by you know
three years later or is that up over
time
the the
the grant program was last year so uh so
about March of last year that it went
out it was spent in four months it's
it's done we will uh that like tracking
of adus goes beyond the beginning of the
grant program or or past you know back
in time to 2018 far before they
implemented the grant uh and um
California's planning department keeps
very good track of the permitting of
these things and so I anticipate I don't
know that exists yet but I I anticipate
they will do a pretty detailed analysis
to determine the effect that Grant had
on production
uh in general they have lots of research
about Adu production in the state not
not specifically about the grant but
just in general
so thank you so that one's relatively
recent is there so maybe something that
maybe has a little bit more of a history
to it I know that that you know uh
Seattle
just from living there I know that the
parking was a big it's a big issue We
complain about parking here it's not the
same thing we don't have an issue with
parking in New Hampshire
um Seattle definitely does
um more than than we do so I guess there
do did they have additional restrictions
kind of like we have in New Hampshire
about
you know parking requirements and and
setback requirements and those other
hurdles that we you know detach versus
and
um attached that we have in New
Hampshire we have placed on ourselves
the legislature has placed on ourselves
um and do you see
any differences there
um as far as
um
implementing any of those changes that
we should probably fix some of those
things first before we implement the
other things or
um Do You See
some places had those restrictions
someplace didn't and it didn't have
really that much effect on these these
uh different kind of plans that you're
talking about here yeah I would in in
several of the case studies uh in States
so the state of Washington the state of
Oregon the state of California
I
uh they've all passed regulations at the
state level that forced the hand of
these local local governing bodies and
so they had choice either respond with
your regulation and and figure out how
you want to manage these things within
the framework of what the state's saying
You must allow
or don't take any action in the state's
default language will take effect and so
um everything within those locations
cities within those locations is kind of
a response to the state level
liberalizing of Adu regulations
thank you Mr chair I didn't see it when
you were going through all the examples
because we've had
um
suggestions of going up to four adus I
believe in a single family lot
what do these other examples
uh you've shown us what are they doing
are they one per or are they multiple
the 480 use it was it's a four plaques
on a single family line whatever okay
whatever but but are they single
thank you for that are they usually just
single adus on a single family building
lot in in the state of California and in
the city of Seattle they allow two adus
and the differentiation is they allow
one uh subordinate Adu within the home
and then they allow a detached one
detection unit and
um this is also found Texas I think
Seattle and Houston do the same thing so
but you know I don't do I recommend that
no I don't think that's necessary I
think we should just create as much
flexibility as possible for one and then
let it let it go let it grow
thank you
anyone else
well thank you very much for your
presenting if you could send us that
PowerPoint that'd be very helpful for us
um I can send you the special committee
email to send that to us my pleasure and
uh if you guys want any help crafting
any kind of programs around New
Hampshire's Adu regulation I'm more than
happy to be a sort of a third party set
of eyes to provide recommendations to
you guys around you know crafting any
kind of scope of work I have a feeling
there'll be a bill submitted
on this stuff next year awesome thank
you thank you
all right so I did want to have a mini
work session at two o'clock but we have
half the committee here so I want to
have like a full committee thank you for
coming representative Walsh
um I appreciate it so I want to schedule
something moving forward
um that will have hopefully the full
committee on
um that'll be like a few hours so we can
hash it out all out
um I know earlier today we represent
McConkey is going to work on some Des
um rule making and recommendations for
that
um but I I guess I kind of want to open
it up and see if there's any anybody
else that's looking at anything
particular
I did watch the presentations this
morning
um and again I figured I could get here
for the workshop I guess just in my
opinion
I couldn't get to my phone for the first
one but both Joe Witcher and I think
it's Ron from Red Oak in my opinion were
probably the most realistic testimony
that this committee has seen so I hope
we can look back at some of their
suggestions in angles when we start
crafting some suggestions one I'll throw
out which Ron said and I believe it was
Ron Ray
the fire department is the most powerful
entity in the state of New Hampshire
isn't this the truth
so just throw this one out there the
problem is it's called The Authority
having jurisdiction which is within the
fire codes which gives the chief or or
designee in each municipality pretty
much fair rape or Fair ability to
interpret on a specific basis those
codes
uh that's terrifying I mean where else
does a single person have that much
power over everybody in the town and I
can give you a dozen examples of
complaints even in my little town in the
last five years and and so so throw this
up for an idea because we felt that the
contractors were being treated unfairly
by the municipalities we created this
thing called the housing appeals board
maybe we ought to give an angle to for
the same reason uh fire code appeals
board it's just something to think about
yeah uh that that some at some point
with these fire codes and and the cost
of them we've got to have some people
just looking at these things and
applying some common sense rather than
just having somebody with an interest
saying no you need this I don't care how
much it costs
I think that's a great an excellent idea
I mean we were taught representative
Wallace was talking about expanding his
language but I think even having
something separate that just deals with
that is good too yes I think it might be
smart to have a you know a two-pronged
approach if you will
um the bill that we were discussing
earlier the the based on the
recommendations of the existing
conditions at the time of issuance uh of
a building permit approval I think we
ought to name all the political
subdivisions as well as any
um agency that may have any type of
authority over it I want to specifically
name the fire department Health
Department uh State Fire Marshal's
office we want to Reign we want to name
them all in particular because as you
know if we're silent on that it's not
included so we name every player that
could be a roadblock for any kind of
development we put them all in there and
uh and I think maybe we do the belt and
suspenders approach and we also have a
You Know PBS a philosophical BS a code
appeals board it could be anything
anything goes
be it zoning fire
um who knows you know Heritage
commission uh you know
rare insect uh Protection Bureau they
all got to be out of our way
or representative yeah and thank you and
even if we have a pushback for growing
government if you will by creating
another layer of bureaucracy uh I guess
as an ombudsman angle as well and so I
mean there's a couple different ways to
approach it just just to get more
neutral eyes on some of these decisions
that are be making been making by by our
bureaucracies
uh and just to clarify what was what my
bill was that representative McConkey
was talking about this morning the
amendment that was put on by the Senate
basically what I've done with this bill
it puts it into I forget the RSA number
now but it puts it right under Municipal
I mean a single-family sprinklers in
other words it pulls sprinklers out of
the codes and says no anything in the
codes that says sprinklers doesn't apply
in New Hampshire
I did the same thing with driveways and
so the amendment that they put on merely
said
um
well I hope you still please listen to
us uh so I was okay with that and so I
hopefully he concurs with it but but
yeah at some point it's costing our
citizens a fortune and unfairly we got
to get a hold on this so if we can
figure out a way like the housing
appeals board or the right to know
Ombudsman to streamline the approach
where if a citizen feels agreed by this
maybe they perceive egregious fire code
buyer code rule they can go and be like
this is kind of absurd can you look at
this and it would streamline it instead
of like a have to take it to court right
yeah not a bad idea I mean
representative yeah I kind of I'm not
sure that we need a whole separate
appeals board I don't know why we
couldn't just expand the housing appeals
board to be able to hear those cases
um but
but
um I'm I'm interested in kind of
um
you said representative McConkey is
talking about trying to do something
um to
I guess influence the rule making of Des
I'm not sure how that is achieved
without actual like just legislation
that says that they have to consider X Y
or Z or they have to do
um you know something along those lines
I'm not sure how that is achieved but
I'm also interested in like how is this
should this committee be
um like go like working with OLS or
something on on drafting now because
normally we're not allowed to really
draft things outside of the normal draft
time and so how is this committee going
to you know be drafting stuff getting it
printed and working on it kind of for
these work sessions or is it all going
to be just like you know back of the
napkin kind of stuff until we go to OLS
um can you
I suggest how we're gonna I don't know
if we're allowed to maybe somebody else
has more but I don't know if we're
allowed to buy are we allowed to buy a
language right now or we no no we can't
file anything drafts actually but as far
as the rule making process we've granted
Des pretty wide authority to do that
however we can constrain the the depth
and breadth of the rules that they make
by putting guardrails through the gel
car process and that's pretty
straightforward process
sort of uh so you know we certainly can
do things like that
um and that's
that's typically the solution when we
find an agency that is run amok and
taken their Authority a bit too far will
say well you can make rules
to this point but not Beyond
so to answer your question I think we
should have when we have the full
committee work session give everybody
something to file with OLS
so I'm thinking maybe end of June have
something where we all have our mission
of what to what to put in right you put
in something regarding which I'm like
I'm
I'm sure some of the representatives are
not going to be like hey I want I you
know one of the things in this committee
that we really should do is get it
nailed down like this is what the
committee kind of like likes as the idea
and it's hard to do that without
actually any language that we can
critique right if you you come in with
the draft from you know an Adu bill
from representative Reed
and and then you know representative
McConkey or or I have a criticism of it
like that the benefit of having this
committee and getting all of these
things that is getting that hashed out
beforehand and not have it
um you know where they file it and then
it comes to this committee or it comes
to another committee and then they have
you know 15 different amendments and
they dies because it's not ready for
prime time I thought that a lot of this
committee was going to be
you know helping get it to Prime Time
now that we have a bunch of ideas like
how do we get that language
um
kind of in draft form so that we can
nitpick it and get it ready for prime
time so for a filing with the rules with
OLS and stuff like that I I think that
maybe we need to talk to the speaker
about like hey can we draft get get
approval for the committee to get some
things drafted maybe it's an amendment
to you know you know
you know HB 1000 right and we're just
drafting some amendment that is not
actually going to go anywhere but is
able to be worked on while this
committee is kind of in
you know maybe something that is
retained or something right that we can
like officially have this bill as the
thing that we can draft amendments to
that we can work with OLS and get
something here for all the committee
members to critique
Kristen I have a question are we allowed
to get language drafted this summer or
do we have to wait
that would be great I mean I have a bill
in judiciary we could just like put some
stuff like find amendments to and stuff
to look at language but and exactly I
think you know let's let's
this the very special committee on
special committee on housing exists
because this is a critical issue at this
point in time so that being said I don't
think we should have to wait for the
fall to start working on this
everybody's here we've been we've been
fact-finding and listening and Gathering
data at this point in time we've got
we've got some you know we've got a lot
of ideas flying around in this
brainstorming session let's get them
down let's talk about amongst ourselves
and then we can hit the ground running
and not and like you say that's a great
idea we want to be ready come up OLS uh
you know filing season in September
we don't have to then wait for it for
January for amending we've got this
stuff worked out amongst us we take it
and run it from there but we probably
will need the speaker's blessing yeah
and we got to bring in probably David
for a day like in August we could work
on it all day
no that's not up to me we wouldn't mind
okay representative Austin yeah just
just
we do have an abundant amount of
information I've been trying to keep
track with notes and things as we go
along
um just for trying to make this all work
I mean this committee I think should
kind of start with an outline whether
it's generated by you or staff or
whatever in a workshop add things to the
outline we need to prioritize and come
through a consensus of what we think we
even need to be moving forward with uh
because we could have come two
completely ideas and of what you need to
do and if we don't have a consensus
we're just going to fight each other
nothing's going to get accomplished I
think there's plenty we found out that
we do agree on
but we got to start someplace
um once we figure out what we're going
to concentrate on then I think it gets
easier and the question gets easier to
answer correct how we're going to do it
and if we can get some strong you know
unanimous or pretty close to it
committee consensus that's going to send
a very strong message in terms of filing
in the fall too I think you can put 10
co-sponsors on a bill that's right well
it sounds like the 10 people who might
be on this that would be the ideal is
that all and it's kind of uh this is
we've done our research
go ahead
um one of the things that we kind of
talked about was this like pre
um
um like off-site building of structures
or they were just talking about plans
here today that were kind of like
pre-approved at the you know county
level or or got stamped automatically
um they do that kind of stuff with the
manufactured housing
um especially you know at the federal
level and maybe
um
I am interested in one of the things
um of having either empowering the
planning commissions or or even NH New
Hampshire like the New Hampshire uh what
Finance Authority or whatever I don't
to come up with a place where we can
have you know
um adus that are pre-approved or houses
that are pre-approved this plan not the
actual like site work and all of that
stuff to to try and reduce the cost
um of either design or like someone just
wants to you know build a house and they
you know are on a fixed budget they want
to build it themselves or whatever they
just would take this plan off and as
long as they can reproduce that plan
congratulations that house is you know
they don't want to design anything right
I think that going to the you know
um local municipality with a Prius
stamped approved plan and you're just
gonna you know okay now I just have this
square and I'm gonna have you know a
plan for the you know the the foundation
or whatever and that's the only thing
that's really at contention at the local
level I think that could speed up the
process and I I would like us to move
um or consider that as something whether
that be the off-site building like
pre-approval plans the 3D construction
approval plans
um uh or these Adu approval plans I
think all of those we could have like an
um kind of a
a Rolodex of things that have been
approved to help spring Streamlight the
process so that the local municipalities
aren't aren't redoing the work every
yeah so let's so let's Center this to
um Kristen can you take notes for this
um could we just Center the specific
issue areas that like broad surface
level what we kind of wanna
like let's start big and then go down so
I'm thinking first
adus
representative Walsh do you have one
well I just mentioned my regulations one
with fire fire and all your other boards
that may affect boards or or
bureaucracies that may affect the
decision-making process okay an appeals
process streamline cheap appeals process
streamlining appeals process for
um
unfavorable decisions to the problem
unfavorable decisions to development
sounds like housing appeals that's gonna
that ought to help we know what that
means
um okay who else
I mean I already said one but I also
think that the um like des and their
um I would say uh
not uh not not taking into account
um like the facts on the ground of what
is the
house or the load that's going to be you
know they're they're calculating 150
gallons per day per bedroom
you know I I think that that is an art
outdated arbitrary some some bad word
archaic you know a bunch of bad words
um that we should we should um consider
um you know requiring Des to actually
consider the things that are on the
ground and not just some arbitrary
number that they've put which may be you
know in effect way before even low flow
toilets even existed
um and
um also kind of like
um
I think that
uh
yeah so I think DS uh
their answers were not
um
I wouldn't say uh
encouraging me that they are they are
flexible
um as far as what is
they they have they seem to just have a
rigid guideline of like this many
bedrooms we're going to approve four
bedrooms that's our standard like they
don't have what if you're building a
one-bedroom house why do you have to
build a four bedroom
um
uh septic system a four bedroom minimum
septic it just doesn't make any sense so
I think that we should look into so some
way to allow for more flexibility yeah
if you if you want to build a
one-bedroom septic system and you're
building a one-bedroom house I don't see
why that's not allowed yeah I hate to
see it once you get the excavator in
there all your materials and supplies
it's probably not going to be that much
of a difference that's exactly right if
you do allow them to build a one bedroom
septic system you're pretty much locking
the house in from ever being able to put
an addition on it etc etc I mean when
you look at the cost difference between
one and four in a septic system with
everything that's involved I bet you
it's insignificant but that's just my
well you're exactly right I haven't had
testimony to that fact it's possible 200
bucks difference do you have something
no
Okay so
what is it oh Josh
um so I was looking at so other than
those what else we have
processes so what you're saying uh
representative Joe Kelly is you'd like
to see Des take a data set driven fax of
the matter case-by-case basis to septic
loading on a particular site as a
function of
percolation rate of the particular soils
and not just some cookie cutter
Arboretum
uh 150 gallons per bedroom per user
right I think I I wouldn't necessarily
say per site I might say something like
hey are you you're you're going to
design you know 25 gallons per bedroom
or does you know or less or 50 gallons
per bedroom or less or 100 gallons per
bedroom or less like this is kind of
like how you're gonna design this this
property and then maybe we have some
guideline set for that and so you would
get you would get your approval based on
you know you said a hundred gallons per
day per bedroom that that is what your
approval for you know that makes this a
three
you know bedroom apartment or a three
bedroom system if you change that to 150
maybe it's only a two bedroom system
right or something like that and so it
might you know have like a grid that
that your
and so it's not just one Sis one one
option there's you can come in and say
I'm gonna I'm building you know based on
all these low flow where I'm having a
compostable toilet that you know or
whatever and so I'm going I'm shooting
for
two bed you know 25 gallons per you know
and so that would be on this chart and
that would make my you know
and so it would be that'll be a
non-stata
it would be
um based on
someone someone uh
the design person would design the
building to meet certain
like thresholds right if there was
different thresholds instead of just
there's only one threshold it's 150
gallons per day per per uh and so I
think that's an inappropriate to only
have one threshold all right so I don't
think that was a hot button for any of
the developers at this point I have a
memo from housing action New Hampshire
with 10 policy
they sent it to us before so I'm gonna
just start from number one streamlining
Municipal inspections
I think that's something that's
something that we can yeah is coordinate
um you know if you need Municipal
inspections have it all happen at one
time allow for that
One Stop Shop for permitting
um number two is improve New Hampshire's
Adu law so we're already working on that
number three is des report on water
Sewer Septic so they said proposed
legislation could Direct Des to provide
legislature with a report on current
water Sewer Septic standards advise on
updates to the science outline needing
statutory recommendations accommodate
increased housing needs so basically
what I what I heard today from Des is
that there's some
there's some rules that have been there
since like 1973 and like
we asked about updated technology and
how it's affecting the rulemaking
process and I I don't see the connection
between that so I want to see more of
that so maybe some legislation that
would require that
um like they use they inform us of you
know new tech inform the
um environment and AD committee every
every biennium on
um new technologies or something about
that
the general court just to kind of update
us on that so that they're looking at it
and then we're also informed on it I
don't know how everyone feels represent
Damon I would agree with that and I
would say maybe we or our researcher do
some background work on the standards in
other states I mean sure there's
different Terrain in different places
and I can't believe I'm going to say
this out loud but you know Hampshire is
not completely unique I mean
we could we could find out what's up to
date elsewhere yeah the I mean the 150
gallons per bedroom kind of thing was a
little like like why this number and
they said it was conservative and I'm
like what's conservative to use
no representative Damon maybe is a
little different than conservative to
you well and I think he seemed to not be
open to
recognizing the advances in for instance
a washing machine that uses 25 of the
water that used to be common in a
washing machine and those are standard
washers now yeah and and the argument is
is you could replace it with something
else that isn't as efficiency but yes
all of these are being built high
efficiency now it was the 150 gallons
per bedroom because I missed part of
that this morning what what period of
time is that
per day
that's huge that's a lot I don't think I
although you could probably use 50
gallons in a shower without too much
trouble but
oh yeah
yes per bedroom per day is this is what
they've been using
so that I so number three definitely Des
report something Kristen around
um requiring Des to provide the general
court with
um new technologies you know we could
direct it to the environmental AG
committee or what some committee or the
Senate General Court whatever
um number four is commercially zoned
opportunities proposed legislation could
incentivize infill residential housing
within certain Zone commercial
yeah I like that
um like the mixed I guess it's like
mixed use where you're doing business on
the lower lower floors and and like
apartments above it kind of a thing
um
what we can look at is there anything on
the state level that's stopping towns
from doing that already and I don't
think there is already it's already I
mean some places allow it
um I I'm not I'm not as limited
um I think that there's I think that
um
there I would also like to consider
incentivizing municipalities to move
away from
um just
um
lot acre requirements that are not tied
to soils soil type for
um
for properties that have
um on-site sewer and septic
um refused to mandate anything from the
state level that tells the municipality
what to do with their lot sizes period
end of story we'll we can argue until
we're that's fine I'm happy to propose
It Anyways that's yeah you might not get
all ten yeah
but I think I think that that is
important okay so number five I have
infield development proposed legislation
could create reasonable opportunities
for infill development in urban Suburban
villages Town centers in zones that
otherwise don't allow multi-family
residential development again I think
that's a top-down thing I kind of don't
want to look at and correlated sorry
it's okay
I think correlated with that
use of
malls old schools I mean properties that
could become housing I don't know how we
would look at that but I think it's
something that might incorporate into
that yeah repurposing existing
structures repurposing existing okay
um fourplexing growth areas so we had
this fourplex bill I don't think we want
to touch that as a committee
um number seven owners parking
requirements proposed legislation could
establish a reasonable parking
requirements eliminate onerous
requirements that often result in empty
paved Lots impose costly barriers to
Housing Development
I don't know how much yeah what appetite
there is for that I agree that there
could be an issue with some cases
but as like I said on the planning board
for 13 years
we we went too far with minimal parking
requirements and it was a nightmare and
and it was actually the developers and
the tenants that asked us to increase
them because
it might sound like a good idea and
might sound affordable to reduce the
parking spaces as much as you can until
you need them so I'm not opposed to the
idea but how we come up with that
formula could be the challenging part
the form right yeah
the only the only thing I see is is
completely reasonable is the Adu if you
have one bedroom only being up like if
you have a one bedroom Adu I don't see
you having you can require more than one
off
um off street parking
I don't know where the appetite is on
that I don't I don't think that's two
onerous
right exactly
um number eight onerous lot size and
arbitrary house home sizes minimum
proposed legislation could limit onerous
lot sizes for Housing Development and
open up opportunities for smaller
starter homes
I don't know what we think about that
I do I do um we heard earlier today that
there was a you know a requirement of a
certain square footage for these
apartments I think that there should not
be any now that I think that we should
have eliminated minimum square footage
requirements when we instituted the tiny
Home Building requirements or the
building code because the building code
now for those tiny homes now treats how
to do those those smaller square foot
properties safely and so I don't I think
that requiring
anything
um you know less than Square 400 square
feet or whatever their there's already a
code for that and how to do it safely
and so I think that
um
any
um size requirements are now essentially
should have been removed already when
when we uh
when we put that building code in
no lot not lot size you're talking about
square footage requirements like I have
to build a 500 or a 10 000 square foot
house right my house is smaller than the
how the requirement that they were
saying for apartments they were saying
what 800 square feet for apartments
800 square feet for an apartment my
whole house is smaller than that right
and there and so I think right exactly
and so so I think all of those are
arbitrary and and should not be allowed
I didn't hear much of it I I recall the
conversation on the apartments today I'm
gonna have to look I'm not even sure if
my town has a square footage requirement
for the actual building size how many
towns do we know have that for single
families
in many towns and then the code when
Bill McKinney came in and talked about
code
um he said that you could build an
apartment 170 square feet and it would
be up to code so
I I think this is one of these
situations where this is a the only
thing that's in places to deter and not
do I mean right it's not a safety
concern so we have to find like if
there's actually a reason for it
restricting like having a minimum
a minimum size or not
just just later this whole process that
we're going through a little bit more
once we determine the list of things we
think need to be tackled we might then
want to look at subcommittees to tackle
some of these things to actually dig
into the weeds yeah so I mean it's gonna
be a lot of fun it's going to be a great
summer it's going to be awesome and and
fortunately
um we are breaking from July to August
15th but we'll have time so I'm gonna
have Kristen help put all this together
for us and then we'll establish
subcommittees from there but the last
one
yes like the housing committee is
breaking
everybody has to yeah for six weeks
so the last one I have is enable
pre-permanenting permitting so um James
brought this up a little bit but most
legislation could enable municipalities
to pre-approve sites for multi-family
Housing Development that meets certain
fire safety design and health standards
so
um maybe if there's like a
blueprint like a pre-approved blueprint
or something template I love that idea
of pre-approved designs that
save people an enormous amount of
process and expense
you know I unfortunately didn't hear all
those presentation this time but I heard
it previously
um
you know the idea of there being half a
dozen different designs people could
pick from that maybe the state creates
I think that would be awesome go ahead
and that on that I agree because I heard
the statement before I can get online
right now and look at tens of thousands
of architect designed house plants and
floor plans and I'm sure there's
somebody doing it for adu's now too I
just don't know where the government
needs to continue to get in to offer
things like that it's a unless they went
in and said these are the designs that
would be approved and you wouldn't need
an inspection for well everything's
going to be everything's going to need
to be inspected for quality and and for
completion you're not gonna you're not
going to get away from that yeah
well you're talk you're talking about
inspections once it's built that's we're
I'm talking about like the approval
process that
getting to the actual like building of
the thing so the design is happening
before you're not designing it after you
built it right you're building you have
the design before building and so I do
like that I I'm concerned with this you
know we can't meet for six weeks or
whatever are we going to be able to meet
as a committee before that starts to
give us like the list of all the things
and
um that we need to be working on and
maybe give each of you know assign those
P you know address you know create a
draft for this topic and have it ready
for the end of the six weeks when we'll
start up again with D um you know uh OLS
and we're going to all amend it to you
know
we're just gonna say say you're mending
you know HB 111 or whatever and
we'll just have all your amendments for
HB 111 on when we come back for the six
weeks or whatever can we have that all
nailed down before the six weeks or
whatever yeah I'm gonna have go ahead do
I mean it
I yeah you could like you could throw it
on anything we don't I just wanna I
think right right I don't think it I
think the mechanism is just any bill
that hasn't been disposed of we can
technically draft an amendment too it
doesn't have to be submitted to the
floor or whatever you know it would just
draft an amendment and and use that to
work in the committee session and so
then we would have like you know and
then it could even be posted online that
people
um you know we could have this committee
have you know Amendment you know we're
going to be hearing amendments you know
blah blah blah so that we could have you
know people come in say like Hey we're
you know uh we're concerned about this
amendment it's drafted this way and you
know you get the public notice and you
get the you know some feedback even
possible ideally for when the bill is
introduced I mean that's great but if uh
part of work sessions is that some
people
know know what we're talking about and
come and give feedback and say that's
not a great idea because as much um
expertise as we have on the committee
there's you know other people that we
have come and speak to us for a reason
that they can shed some light on I don't
know if I can miss the chair I think
Simplicity wise we've been charged with
the task of trying to find Solutions we
weren't given any bills I think we
continue our task of trying to find the
solutions and working on getting some
draft legislation for next year I don't
think I don't see the need to start
trying to attach non-germaine amendments
etc etc because at the end of the day
we're not going to be able to act on
those until January anyway when the same
time we'll be up if this committee still
exists or our bills go to Municipal
either that they'll be dealing with them
in January as well we're not saving a
whole lot of time and if it's any help I
don't know if you saw the big news on TV
today that the rent prices are finally
relieving it's a national Trend the free
Market's actually starting to work when
demand goes down so do the prices so did
we just solve it not doing anything I I
don't think we should
I I was never suggesting attaching
anything
yes we need amendments to be able to
have actual language to critique in this
committee like otherwise we're doing
just random like I wrote this down on a
piece of paper and now we're going to
critique it I'm saying that
how the mechanism for drafting anything
through Los you OLS you actually have to
have something to attach it to because
there's you cannot request a bill to be
drafted a new bill to be drafted until
Bill filing season and so how do you
actually have OLS actually attach or
draft you anything you have to have a
mechanism and I'm suggesting the
mechanism could be an amendment we don't
actually put in the amendment we don't
actually we just have it drafted so that
we can work on it and have something
here in the committee to work on and
then we actually take that drafted
Amendment and actually file it next year
as a new bill I'm not actually saying
that we do non-germain amendments okay I
understand what you're saying we would
just use it as a vehicle I do too but
again I think we're four steps ahead of
it first we need to know what we even
want to say so so action items I'm gonna
have Kristen just throw together a small
memo for us to see like issue areas I'm
going to send it to the committee have
everybody sign up to volunteer on
subcommittees and I want to have a work
session before we break for July July to
August 15th I want to have a work
session where we can coordinate
committees and have everybody work on
those and then we can come together in
like September like late August early
September and kind of hash out what we
got yeah and if we can once we get that
initial outline I think it gives
everybody an opportunity to look at it
go through their notes and maybe do a
draft b or a second draft on you and
I'll send out an email and ask who is
interested on serving a committee to
look at
um requiring Des to you know publish or
present to the general court every two
years or something
okay so two quick things and I apologize
if I missed this was there a discussion
about evaluating impact fees further and
also was there any conversation about
looking at the lag time in the state
adopting more up-to-date building code
so that's what we are so those are good
questions Kristen threw together a memo
regarding impact fees I think it's
something that we should look at
um there was a recommendation that there
I think the city of Dover made a
recommendation that we do like targeted
impact fees to certain things so like if
you are to charge an impact fee it could
go because each municipality kind of
chooses where it goes but maybe we could
be like if you are to charge an impact
fee it can go towards
um Economic Development or I don't know
something but or maybe something but
it's on the list yeah so um could you
put impact fees on there as well please
thank you
yeah
all right go ahead James real quick
just real quick while you're talking
about pressing issues I used to work for
the regional Planning Commission a lot
of what we did is work around
Transportation issues
and one of the things that uh came to my
Discovery over time was that a lot of
municipalities adopt their subdivision
regulations directly from guidance from
New Hampshire D.O.T and uh that Baseline
recommendation is a 50-foot right-of-way
with 24 feet of asphalt X inches thick
and it's kind of Overkill if you're
trying to build a little neighborhood
street to require 50 feet right away and
it it significantly drives up the cost
of subdividing land and so that might be
one of the places where you look at uh
maybe hiring a consultant or working
with a consultant to come up with
recommendations for lower impact lower
cost alternatives to standard roadway
designs for small subdivisions
representative Walsh I have to ask you
the question
don't the planning commissions want
complete streets which are sidewalks
both sides bump outs crosswalks a center
median strip and an Esplanade
and now you're going to tell me that the
Planning Commission is is is is
recommending substandard roads
well let's let's uh imagine for a second
there's a piece of land that could hold
Eight houses on it and it is only
requires a hundred feet of right-of-way
and it's not uh substantial arterial
Road it's a tertiary Road right like
wouldn't it be wonderful if that could
be something as simple as a compacted
gravel or uh stone dust road that is a
shared Lane between pedestrians and cars
people drive slow and it looks like a
camp right like how many of you have
gone to a Lakeside Camp down a little
single Path Road where you have to pull
off the road to let another car go by
like sunshine and rainbows
yeah well it's usually the people that
own those camps that maintain the road
because the town doesn't want to have
anything to do with the dirt one but uh
no it's it's a neat thought
thank you all right is there anything
else for the committee
we don't need to do that but we are
adjourned thank you
foreign